Guten Morgen, Linus.
Guten Morgen, Tim.
Was ist jetzt eigentlich mit Mozilla?
Weg. Kann weg. Weg. Was soll das?
Ich meine, ganz ehrlich, was soll das?
Ich habe hier nur einen Job in dieser Sendung, das ist diese Ansage richtig
straight hinzubekommen. Den kannst du mir nicht wegnehmen.
Also, wenn Mozilla das nicht auch noch streicht.
Dem werde ich mich entgegensetzen, mit aller Kraft. Soll ich anfangen?
Ja.
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 200, 567.385 Millionen und 5 zerquetschte, nein, 502.
Logbuch Netzpolitik 502 vom 30.
September 2024. Es ist Quartalsende. Heute wird abgerechnet. Heute wird mit Mutzela.
Ja, weil aus der Kategorie Was erlaube, haben wir ein bisschen Stress mit Mozilla.
Aus der Kategorie Next Level erlaube, was überhaupt noch.
Möchtest du dein Klagelied erheben? Ja.
Um diese Sendung vorzubereiten, nutzen wir einen verteilten Bookmark-Dienst.
Ursprünglich war das Instapaper von Marco Ahmendt geschrieben,
der hat es irgendwann verkauft, war völlig in Ordnung.
Aber irgendwann war Pocket besser. Pocket, Get Pocket. Nicht auf die Seite gehen.
Getpocket.de.
Warum hat sich das empfohlen? Weil
man dafür ein Browser-Plugin in alle gängigen Browser haben konnte und dann
gab es auch zum Beispiel für iOS und iPadOS und Safari und Chrome oder was man
alles so hat und dann kann man auf den unterschiedlichen Geräten Webseiten besuchen und sagen,
das ist eine Webseite für Logbuch-Netzpolitik,
dann klickt man auf Save to Pocket und dann ist das da gespeichert.
Und das geht auf unterschiedlichen Geräten, also auch dann auf Tims Geräten,
so unterschiedlich können die sogar sein, also jemand anders gehören,
der auf dem gleichen Account eingeloggt ist und so haben wir alle für die Sendung
relevanten Links gesammelt.
Und dann haben wir auf der Pocket App, die dann, das ist eine Standalone App,
die man auf dem Mac starten kann, da sieht man dann die ganzen gespeicherten
Links und wenn man dann eine Seite sich angeschaut und ein C gedrückt hat,
dann hatte man den Link zu der Seite in der Zwischenablage und konnte ihn in
dem Dokument, in dem wir die Shownotes machen, pasten.
Das war über, Wir machen diese Sendung seit 13 Jahren.
Ich würde sagen, die letzten 10 Jahre haben wir das so gemacht. Und dann...
Echt?
Oder mindestens 8. Also der Wechsel von Instapaper auf Pock.
Naja, du hast dann irgendwann, du hast Jahre später angefangen mitzumachen.
Aber ich habe jetzt wirklich...
So weit würde ich nicht gehen.
Und jetzt...
Achso, man konnte noch andere Sachen machen. Zum Beispiel konnte man sich die
gespeicherten Links als RSS-Feed rausgeben lassen.
Das haben sie aber schon vor einiger Zeit kaputt gemacht.
Was besonders ungeil ist, weil man dann nicht einfach mal auf irgendeinem sekundären
Medium wie einem Chat zum Beispiel sich das einfach reinspielen lassen kann
oder in so einem Newsreader und dadurch verliert man sozusagen auch den Kontakt
zur Aktivität der anderen Personen.
Es gab da mal, Tim hatte zum Beispiel eine Bridge zu Slack, weil er nicht die
Desktop-App benutzen wollte, sondern Slack.
Warum auch immer man das benutzen wollen würde, aber es ging.
Vollkommen egal, was benutzt man, auch ein normaler Newsreader, da lief das ja auch rein.
RSS, ein Format wie ein Gedicht.
Und dann haben sie, vor einem Jahr haben sie uns RSS genommen,
dann brauchte man irgendwie ein API-Token, das ist auch schon wieder länger
her, dann habe ich sogar noch die Skripte umgeschrieben, um mit der ein API zu reden.
Und jetzt funktioniert die Mac-App nicht mehr, man braucht die iPad-App und
was passiert jetzt, wenn man jetzt, also wenn ich jetzt aus dieser App,
wenn ich aus dieser App, ich gucke in dieser App, ich sehe meinen Artikel,
er ist quasi am Hauptbahnhof in München, ist der Artikel.
Jetzt dauert es aber 10 Minuten, bis du dir das Notizdokument bekommst.
So, jetzt, es ist nicht mehr und, Und, also jetzt, Moment, ich gucke mal über
Artikel. Achso, jetzt bin ich in einer anderen Pocket-App wieder.
Boah, das ist einfach ein Traum. Wir können Podcast jetzt aufhören.
Jetzt muss ich.
Deswegen gibt es heute keine Shownotes.
Genau, Shownotes wurden jetzt abgeschafft.
Von Motrilla.
Im Kampf um das offene Web wurden die Shownotes abgeschafft.
Jetzt muss ich, pass auf, ich kann das gar nicht, ich will es ja jetzt gerne
beschreiben, was ich machen muss, aber ich muss erst einmal,
ich kann es mir gar nicht merken.
Also, ich betrachte die Seite, ich, wenn ich jetzt C drücke,
passiert nichts, dann muss ich oben auf die drei Dinger,
zweiter Klick, dritter Klick, Share, dann geht dieses also erst mal kommt hier
ein Grafikfehler und dann auf Copy, ja? Fünf Klicks!
Kein Keybinding, weil iPhone hat keine Tastatur.
IPad schon.
IPad hat Tastatur, braucht man aber nicht. Also funktioniert nicht.
Und wenn ich jetzt dann in die Notes gehe und mache Apfel V,
dann kommt da der Link und er lautet https://
pocket.co share uuid und dann kommt noch Fragezeichen utm underscore source
equals pocket reader. Das heißt, wir haben jetzt Tracking-Links da drin.
Nicht nur das, es ist halt auch alles Redirect.
Und die sehen alle gleich aus, ich kann sie nicht mehr kontrollieren.
Ich könnte jetzt die Skripte umschreiben, dass sie halt irgendwie dem Redirect
folgen und dann versuchen, aber nee.
Das Problem ist, es gibt überhaupt gar keine guten Bookmark-Manager da draußen.
Also ich weiß nicht so ganz genau, für wen die Skript gemacht sind,
aber für uns sind sie auf jeden Fall nicht.
Es gibt schon mal überhaupt keine, wo du mit mehr als einem Account irgendwie
in derselben Datenbasis arbeiten kannst oder wo du beim Abwerfen einer URL mal
sagen kannst, für welches Projekt das jetzt ist.
Es gibt immer nur so einen globalen Speicher für eine Person und das machen
alle so. Das ist wirklich zum Heulen.
Und dieses Pocket war im Prinzip, der einzige Vorteil von Pocket war auch nur
so, das lief so halbwegs irgendwie und man konnte das auch so mühelos mal eben
auf dem Telefon zum Abwerfen benutzen. Da gibt es auch ein paar andere Sachen.
Aber das eigentliche Problem ist, dass Mozilla jetzt wohl in der großen Problematik,
ihre Projekte nicht mehr finanzieren zu können, einen Weg einschlägt,
der problematisch ist in vielerlei Hinsicht.
Und einer davon ist, dass auch dieses Pocket dafür verwendet wird,
jetzt Homepages im Firefox zu befüllen und darüber irgendwie indirekt Geld zu verdienen.
Und deswegen wird das jetzt alles wieder in so einen Modus ausgerichtet,
wo man sagt, wir müssen jetzt auf die Masse gehen.
Und dann ist dann so eine Macintosh-App, die vielleicht Leute wirklich mal produktiv
benutzt haben, haben die Sache schon nicht mehr wert. Nimm doch die iPad-App, läuft auch.
Nur, dass die iPad-App halt überhaupt nicht die Bedürfnisse bedient,
die man so auf dem Desktop braucht und so dreht sich das alles immer im Kreis.
Ich hätte das alles noch mitgemacht, aber Tracking-Links?
Für ein freies Internet.
Für das offene Web.
Für das offene Web, ja. Offenes Web ist vorbei. Also es ist einfach,
es ist jetzt einfach also für Mozilla.
Die nehmen da nicht mehr dran teil. Ja, also jetzt haben wir unserem Ärger Luft
gemacht. Das war doch alles, was wir wollten, oder?
Markus, aber für Netzpolitik.org ist das gut, sagst du?
Achso, Pocket, ja. Also Pocket ist ja die, ich glaube, es gibt keinen,
also Pocket, also nicht die App, sondern dieses Ding, wenn man beim Firefox
keine Startseite einstellt, dann kriegt man solche, es gibt solche Fenster.
Ladies and Gentlemen, Ich höre Schlimmeln.
Komm, den holen wir jetzt mal rein.
Wir kennen ihn alle.
Markus Netzpolitik-Agent.
Markus Reuter.
Nachdem du fünf Jahre nicht mehr hier warst, dachten wir so.
Immerhin habt ihr mich noch erkannt.
Den können wir schon noch mal holen. Der war jetzt so schlecht. Nicht.
Ja, hallo. Herzlich willkommen bei Logbuch Netzpolitik. Politik,
du siehst, wir müssen uns am Anfang erstmal ein bisschen, ja,
Linus muss erstmal Dampf ablassen und so weiter, das ist ja so unausgeglichen.
Ich habe euch ja auch fünf Jahre nicht mehr gehört, macht ihr das immer so?
Raus!
Ja, du hast ja jetzt auch mal mitbekommen, wie das anfängt, bevor aufgenommen wird.
Das sind alles natürlich Einblicke, die werden wir heute mit den Hörerinnen
und Hörern nicht teilen.
Aber sie haben jetzt, also nochmal Pocket, die haben jetzt wirklich das Zustandekommen
dieser Sendung massiv erschwert.
Ich werde mir echt was überlegen müssen, weil das...
Ja, ich kenne es nur von der anderen Seite aus also von diesen Kacheln,
die man im Firefox sieht und wenn man da erscheint mit einem Artikel,
Ich hasse Mozilla jetzt Aber es bringt dir locker 130.000 Reader,
die bei dir vorbeikommen Okay.
Das heißt, eigentlich sollten wir diese Tracking-Links nehmen und sehr häufig aufrufen Ja.
Genau Auf jeden Fall, ja, also bislang war das Stärkste irgendwie,
ein Spiegellink bringt dir, wenn sie verlinken,
2000 Klicks irgendwie, ein Fefe-Link brachte irgendwie zu guten Zeiten 10.000,
Pocket 40.000 bis 200.000.
Und das merkt man dann immer, wenn man komische E-Mails bekommt von Leuten, die sich beschweren.
Weil ihr gendert oder meinungen habt. Oder worüber beschweren die sich bei euch? Gendern und?
Meistens, ja genau. Also wir sind auf Pocket, merkt man, du kriegst E-Mails
mit Leuten, die sich über das Gendern beschweren.
Ist denn das dann so hilfreich, dann diese Distribution zu haben?
Naja, ich meine, eine große Reichweite zu kriegen auf einen Artikel ist schon
hilfreich, wenn man Themen groß machen will.
Aber ich meine, wird es dadurch auch wirklich groß?
Ich glaube schon.
Wie glaub? Du bist Journalist, du musst ja wissen.
Ja, wie soll ich jetzt politischen Impact messen?
Achso bewegbaren Publikum scharfkantig zu publizieren oder hat man was davon,
in die Breite zu gehen und dabei viele Leute zu erreichen, die,
am Ende eh nichts damit anfangen können oder deren Partizipation dann in diesem
Prozess auch vielleicht zumindest in Teilen kontraproduktiv durch hohes Kommentar,
rauschen, was man dann nicht mehr so meint.
Das gibt es bei Netz für Tick-Ock eh nicht mehr, oder?
Das ist eine Ergänzung. Ich glaube schon, dass es das bringt,
wenn viele Leute sehen und das merke ich schon, wenn so ein Artikel da ist,
letztens einer zu diesem Überwachungspaket,
dann regen sich Leute auf, da wird es größer.
Ein Thema, was sonst vielleicht eine spitze Zielgruppe, was ich,
10.000 Leute gelesen, so haben es 130.000 gelesen.
Ich glaube, das macht schon was aus von Druck und wie es sich dann weiter verbreitet
und dann geht es ja nochmal irgendwie, dann teilen es die Leute weiter in ihren
Netzwerken und also ich denke, insgesamt ist das auf jeden Fall gut.
Das heißt, ihr gendert einfach nur, damit ihr sich noch mehr Aufregung kippt in die...
Naja, die können ja sowieso einfach Chat-GPT-Antworten. Ich glaube,
die große Verschwörung ist ja,
dass diese Leute, die einem da die ganze Zeit schreiben und dieses uralte Thema
die ganze Zeit aufmachen, dass die quasi einen beschäftigen wollen und jetzt
beschäftigen wir sie zurück, indem wir ihnen Chat-GPT und dann das Ding nennen.
Und dann so, okay, schreibe eine Antwort, warum das wichtig ist zu gendern.
Und dann immer sage ich immer, und noch länger, noch länger,
noch länger, damit es uns stelle Fragen und dann schickt man das einfach zurück
und dann kriegen die so eine große Antwort.
Und was machen die dann?
Manche antworten dann tatsächlich wieder, also, aber die meisten schreiben einfach
nur und ich glaube, dass ich die komische Type von Mensch, die sich da so aufregt,
so unglaublich, egal, lass uns davon weg.
Okay, doch ein kurzer Signal an all die Nerds, die jetzt sozusagen schon hier,
an all die Nerds, die jetzt schon ihren Lieblings-Bookmark-Manager sozusagen,
also schon schreibbereit jetzt quasi schon in den Kommentaren sitzen.
Ja genau, empfehlt uns bitte noch den richtigen Messenger.
Ihr dürft nur dann kommentieren, wenn ihr erstens meine Kulturreferenz vorhin,
verstanden habt zu Galaxy Quest und zweitens interessieren uns nur Bookmark-Manager,
die Multi-User sind, RSS rauswerfen können und unterschiedliche Databases adressieren
können, also zumindest irgendwie Tagging oder,
womit man halt was unterscheiden kann.
Wenn man sagen kann, dieser Link ist dafür, dieser Link ist dafür.
Dann dürft ihr mir den Tipp geben.
Und den Tipp welchen Messenger?
Und der Link darf nicht verändert werden.
Also nicht ihr Tracking-Link.
Nein, genau. Und die Software, mit der man das auch wieder zurückholt,
die muss auch bedienbar sein.
Also das dünnt es jetzt schon so weit aus, wir werden wahrscheinlich gar keine
Kommentare bekommen. Die muss floss sein.
Oder sie scheitern einfach daran, meine Kulturreferenz zu Galaxy Quest zu erkennen.
Aber sie sollen, dann dürfen sie aber auch direkt noch einen Messenger empfehlen.
Das ist Wahnsinn. Hast du Galaxy Quest gesehen?
Klar.
Wer kennt es nicht?
Das klang dir sehr gut vor. Ist das ein Computerspiel?
Nein, das ist es nicht. Das ist kein Computerspiel. Das holen wir dann später nach.
Du bist ja eigentlich gar kein richtiger Nerd, oder?
Planlos durchs Weltall.
Das ist wirklich einer der lustigsten Filme, die es überhaupt gibt.
Tim Allen.
Ja, ja. Grandios. Genau.
Also ist das irgendwie Spaceballs für...
Nee, ist besser.
Klar ist es besser. Aber,
ich bin wirklich am Boden zerstört, weil ich jetzt nicht weiß,
wie wir diese Sendung, also allein diese Shownotes-Arbeit...
Pass mal auf.
Habt ihr die ab links gesammelt noch?
Ja.
Wie jetzt? Nicht mehr jetzt. Ab jetzt machen wir ohne Quellen.
Genau. Mozilla macht sich Gedanken darüber, wie sie Geld verdienen können. Wir auch.
Deswegen würde ich sagen, machen wir jetzt erst mal unsere Sponsormitteilung. Ja.
Also eine Nachricht von unseren Sponsoren.
Kauft euch das neue iPhone, damit...
Nein, von unseren Sponsoren.
Wir sind unsere Sponsoren, unsere Hörerinnen und Hörer, also das Feedback.
Ah, okay, sehr gute Überleitung.
Genau, das Feedback. Der erste Hinweis war, du hast glaube ich im Eifer des
Gefechts die Wahlcomputer-Problematik nach Sachsen verlagert, war aber Thüringen.
Ja, ich kann jetzt nur Ausreden dafür finden, dass ich Sachsen und Thüringen
verwechselt habe, die alles nur noch schlimmer machen.
Insofern habe ich verwechselt.
Man könnte auch sagen, am Ende auch egal.
Hast du jetzt gesagt, ich habe es verwechselt.
Ja, verwechselt, genau. Genau.
Und dann gab es eher eine Nachfrage, die ich auch kurz kommentiert habe,
die wollte ich hier nochmal kurz in die Sendung tragen, zu den Pager-Anschlägen.
Mirko fragte nämlich, wann wurden denn diese Pager und die Walkie Talkies verteilt,
selbst wenn es nur zwei Wochen vor der Explosion war? Wie wahrscheinlich ist
es, dass keiner der 3000 Hisbollas in diesen zwei Wochen durch eine Flughafensecurity
mit seinem Gerät gegangen ist?
Der Sprengstoff hätte dort doch entdeckt werden müssen und damit wäre die ganze
Aktion aufgeflogen. Ich verstehe es nicht.
Vielleicht habt ihr dazu noch Wissen oder Ideen.
Ja, haben wir.
Haben wir, genau. Denn ich schrub, dass wir das noch hätten erwähnen sollen.
Ich hatte das auch im Kopf, aber dann habe ich es nicht gesagt.
Also soweit ich das gehört habe, waren die schon seit einigen Monaten,
ich habe gehört so sechs Monate schon in irgendeiner Form in Use.
Sind also jetzt nicht gerade ausgegeben worden.
Und außerdem ist es halt so, um diese Explosionen in der Stärke,
wie man sie beobachtet hat,
dort auszulösen, braucht es so irgendwas in der Größenordnung von zwei Gramm Semtex-Sprengstoff.
Das ist so in etwa die Menge.
Und bei Semtex ist es nun mal so, also ich zitiere einfach mal kurz Wikipedia,
hier steht industriell hergestelltes Semtex muss in den meisten Staaten gemäß
Montrealer Übereinkommen mit Markierungsstoffen versetzt werden,
die das Auffinden des Sprengstoffs durch Hunde und Sprengstoffdetektoren ermöglichen.
Und jetzt meinst du etwa, dass Israel gegen das Montrealer Übereinkommen verschlossen hat?
Ich meine überhaupt nicht. Ich sage nur, es ist halt absolut nachvollziehbar,
dass es einen Weg gab, dass die nicht so ohne weiteres am Flughafen aufgefallen
sind bei einer detailliert geplanten Aktion.
Da kann ich zu Semtex was sagen. Eine Kollegin hat es erzählt,
dass wenn man in der Flughafenskontrolle richtig Ärger haben will,
sollte man Lebkuchen mitnehmen, weil das sieht aus wie Semtex. Okay, nur so als.
Ich traue mich nicht mehr.
Aber hatten die das nicht schon, meine Information war, dass da auch schon welche
entdeckt wurden, dass da Sprengstoff drin ist und dass deswegen Zeitdruck entstanden
ist, auch die Dinger in die Luft zu jagen.
Aber okay, das war irgendwie eine, also die hatten glaube ich schon welche aufgemacht
und gesehen, okay, da ist irgendwas.
Okay, ja, also ich habe das ja auch nicht weiter verfolgt jetzt,
muss ich zugeben, in der letzten Woche.
Vielleicht gab es da noch mehr Berichterstattungen, die ich jetzt nicht so gesehen
habe, aber das ist auf jeden Fall erstmal so ein Statement.
Also dann gab es zwei Kommentare, die sich darüber aufgeregt haben,
dass wir bei einem Angriff auf, was war das, zweieinhalbtausend Leute?
Ja, ungefähr.
Mit einer zwei Gramm Semtex-Bombe in ihrer Hand von Präzision gesprochen haben, weil ja auch,
Menschen, die quasi nicht Ziel des Angriffs sein sollten, dadurch verletzt werden könnten.
Und auch teilweise wurden.
Und sicherlich auch wurden, was wir auch in der Sendung anerkannt haben.
Es ist nur sehr unwahrscheinlich, dass man einen Weg findet,
zweieinhalbtausend Menschen anzugreifen, bei dem man noch weniger Unschuldige trifft.
Wir haben spezifisch, das habe ich auch gesagt, dass es quasi die Ratio,
wahrscheinlich bei jedem anderen Angriff, der vorher auf eine so große Menge
Menschen gemacht wurde,
so war das noch mehr Unschuldige mitgetötet wurden oder verletzt wurden.
Insofern verstehe ich diesen Kommentar nicht so ganz.
Aber eventuell habe ich mich da missverständlich ausgedrückt.
Aber irgendjemand meinte auch, wir hätten das gefeiert. Ich weiß nicht,
was daran feiern ist, wenn ich etwas teuflisch nenne.
Aber okay, es gibt einfach auch ehrlich Leute, die sobald irgendwie...
Ja, wir haben da gar nichts gefeiert. Wir haben versucht, das einfach so zu
schildern, wie es passiert ist.
Und natürlich ist das für uns ein spezielles Thema, weil es eben so konkret
mit Technologie und mit Mobilkommunikation zu tun hat.
Ja, aber das einzig wertende Wort war, glaube ich, wenn dann teuflisch.
Gut, kommen wir zum HTTP-Statuscode 502.
Ein Burnout hatte und sich vorerst von seinem aktiven Dienst am Browser zurückgezogen
hat. Ja, und er ist einfach durch.
Und weil durch das Trommelfeuer der Anfragen und Downloads ist er so an die
Grenzen seiner Leistungsfähigkeit geraten und benötigt eine Betriebspause.
Dafür hat er sich zur Erholung an den schönen Kurort Bad Gateway begeben,
um sich dort einem intensiven Loadbalancing zu unterstehen.
Im elektronischen Wellenbad regenerieren sich die Caches und die Leiterbahnen
werden durch einen Datenstrom-Yoga neu aufgebaut. Wusstest du das, Linus?
Wusstest du nicht. Ich sehe es dir an der Nasenspitze an.
Also auf der Suche nach einem stabilen 200er-Zustand streift er die illustre
Umgebung von BART, Gateway,
wie zum Beispiel die schönen Reset-Berge, majestätische grüne Hügel,
auf denen die Server ihre Einstellungen auf den Werkszustand zurücksetzen und
von vorn beginnen können.
Oder die schönen Latenzwiesen, in denen der Systemtakt in Zeitlupe abläuft,
wo man sich fernab jeglichen Traffics die Ping-Zeiten einfach Ping-Zeiten sein lassen kann.
Nach der Wiederherstellung der Funktionen werden dann wieder Daten ausgeliefert.
Aber es kann dauern. Soviel dazu.
Macht ihr das für alle Fehlercodes oder was? So Texte?
Wir haben das lange nicht gemacht.
Das ist eine tiefe Recherche. Wir mussten ja diesen Block, also bei 400 irgendwas
war dann Schluss und dann mussten wir ganz viele Sendungen machen und jetzt
geht es erst bei 500 wieder weiter.
Aber jetzt wollten wir auch mal ein bisschen darauf konzentrieren,
den wahren Grund herauszufinden. Ja, und so ist es halt ein Bartgateway,
kann ich sehr empfehlen.
Hältst du das jetzt für abschließend erörtert oder sollen wir es nochmal...
Ja, okay, gut. Dann kommen wir zum nächsten.
Wir wollen uns denn nicht aufregen heute.
Ich bin gespannt.
Also ich nicht.
Ja.
Deswegen haben wir Markus eingeladen.
Ja, okay, dann mal los.
Sicherheitspaket.
Sicherheitspaket, auch Überwachungspaket genannt.
Also es ist passiert, angeblicher Auslöser war ja ein Angriff in Solingen.
Habe ich das richtig in Erinnerung?
Genau, Messerangriff, mutmaßlicher Täter, 26-jähriger syrischer Asylbewerber.
Genau, der sich dann als ISIS bekannt hat, was ja irgendwie auch jeder kann,
muss einfach nur ein Video machen.
So schnell bist du wirklich auch Terrorist mit deinem Amoklauf.
Okay, da passiert Solingen, schreckliche Tat, drei Menschen sterben, mehrere verletzt.
Warum kenne ich dann die Gesetze, die die jetzt in Reaktion darauf beschließen
wollen, schon von vorher? her.
Genau, die sind aus der Schublade, so quasi. Aber es sind auch Gesetze,
die ja nicht unbedingt helfen gegen diesen Anschlag. Zum Beispiel wenn,
weil jetzt das Neue, was da drin ist, es ist ein Doppelpaket.
Eins ist, es richtet sich hauptsächlich gegen Asylbewerber und Asylbewerberinnen,
ist der eine Teil und der andere ist so ein klassisches Sicherheitspaket, Überwachung und Co.
Und jetzt ist die Maßnahme, damit man keine messerstechenden den ISIS-Leute
hat, ist, wer sein Heimatland als Asylbewerber besucht, der kann abgeschoben werden.
Zum Beispiel jetzt. Oder wer aus einem anderen EU-Land kommt,
wo schon ein Asylverfahren läuft, dann kriege ich da keine Leistung mehr.
So verhindere ich Messerattacken, denkt die Ampel.
Also das sind so Sachen, die jetzt in diesem Asylpaket von diesem Sicherheitspaket
drin sind, unter anderem.
Genau, also es ist eigentlich eine starke Verschärfung der Asylgesetzgebung.
Ich kann jetzt auch dort, die Behörden dürfen jetzt auch zum Beispiel Dateien
aus dem Internet, dürfen noch nicht, das ist ja noch nicht durch das Gesetz,
können jetzt Bildabgleich, Biometrieabgleich machen mit Daten,
Referenzdaten aus dem Netz von Leuten, von Geflüchteten.
Solche Geschichten sind da drin. Das ist das eine, also auf der Asylgesetzgebung,
dann gibt es eine Verschärfung der Waffengesetze, dass jetzt Messer und da bleibt
das Gesetz auch so, dass es Messer einfach nur ist und das kann halt,
es wird nicht definiert, ob das jetzt irgendwie ein Plastikmesser oder ein großes
Messer, ein Buttermesser oder ist es irgendwie ein...
Also was jetzt passiert ist, dass das Führen von Messern verboten wird. Im großen Stil.
Ja, außer du hast es nochmal verpackt, also gekauft ist, eingeschweißt oder
so oder abgeschlossen, dann zählt es nicht so richtig als Messer und es gibt
so ein paar Ausnahmeregelungen.
Also es ist ein sehr weiter Begriff von was ein Messer ist und jetzt,
kann, also das Gesetz enthält dann auch zum Beispiel, dass jetzt die Landesregierung
dürfen bestimmen, wo Messer verboten sind, besonders verboten und dann darf
die Polizei dort anlasslos kontrollieren.
In so eine Kontrolle bin ich kürzlich hier in Berlin geraten.
Aber wahrscheinlich in der Bahn oder im Bahnhof?
Im Bahnhof, ja Habe ich dann auch nachher,
da kam halt irgendwie, läuft sehr lang und dann kommen da irgendwie halt so ein paar Polizisten in,
so ihren komischen Kampfanzügen da und ja allgemeine Personenkontrolle und ich
dachte so ey die macht doch keine allgemeine Personenkontrolle was ist das denn
jetzt für ein Quatsch haben sie Waffen dabei,
Oder irgendwas mit Waffen und dann habe ich gesagt, habe ich irgendwie so einen
Witz gemacht, ich weiß gar nicht, habe ich irgendwie so gesagt,
ja nicht so viele wie sonst.
Und dann machen die direkt und dann war es so, was haben sie dabei?
Und ich so, nix, nix, nix.
Und ich so, der Ausweis irgendwie gezeigt und wenn wir sie jetzt durchsuchen,
finden wir Waffen. Und dann ich so, nein Mann.
Aber das war Aber das ist ein paar Monate her, da war dieser Quatsch noch nicht.
Es gab es davor auch schon so Waffenverbotszonen in Städten zum Beispiel oder
irgendwie an Bahnhöfen durften sie zum Beispiel auch kontrollieren.
Und das wird jetzt ausgeweitet, sodass sich auch an belebten Straßen und an
benachbarten Straßen von belebten Straßen und in Bildungseinrichtungen und Jugendeinrichtungen
und Sportstätten und auf dem Weg zu Sportstätten.
Und jetzt kann ich quasi, das Gesetz erlaubt den Landesregierungen,
da werden sich bestimmt einige Landesregierungen konservativer Couleur sehr freuen,
kann ich eigentlich, kann ich das, was man in der Demokratie nicht haben will,
nämlich, dass alle Menschen immer angesprochen, dass wir, haben sie eine Waffe?
Und dann sagst du, äh, nee, dann, oh, ich bin trotzdem verdächtigt,
darf ich mal in ihre Tasche schauen und dann kann ich durchsuchen und die Schranken dafür sind relativ,
leicht, die Polizei darf nämlich selber einschätzen, wie das ist,
also was ihr Verdachtsmoment dann quasi ist, also sie kann anlasslos fragen
und dann sagen, oh, jetzt hab ich einen Verdacht,
und kann dann jeden durchsuchen und das ist halt, das will man nicht haben,
das ist Schleierfahndung, ne, also das ist ja, sind Personenkontrollen von unbescholtenen
Menschen, die irgendwo rumlaufen und dann
gucken die bei mir rein und dann keine Ahnung, ich hab keinen Bock,
dass sie irgendwie in meine Taschen schauen, es geht die nicht an,
was ich dabei hab, welche Bücher ich lese,
welche, was weiß ich, Geschichten, welchen Computer ich dabei hab oder was auch immer.
Das wird ausweiten,
Dass man überall kontrolliert werden kann. Das ist ein Teil des Gesetzes.
Also anlasslose Kontrollen, fast schrankenlos überall.
Also das, was da jetzt vor ein paar Monaten bei mir passiert ist,
weil ich da langgelaufen bin und einfach der Verdächtigste war,
der denen gerade unter das Auge gekommen ist, das kann jetzt nicht mehr nur
an diesem Bahnhof passieren, sondern überall.
Genau, bislang war das sehr eingeschränkt. Anlasslose Kontrollen gibt es im
Zollgrenzbezirk, das heißt also um die Außengrenzen Deutschlands,
an Flughäfen, an Bahnhöfen und an kriminalitätsbelasteten Orten oder so.
Also das haben sie auch schon ausgeweitet immer weiter, aber es gibt einen guten
Grund diese Schleierfahndung nicht zu machen, weil ich eben Menschen,
unschuldige, unbescholtene Menschen irgendwie auf einmal durchsuche und den
Staat geht es einen feuchten Kehricht an, was ich dabei habe,
solange ich unbescholtener Mensch bin.
Ich hatte die, ich hatte, hat das was mit diesen Gefahrenzonen zu tun?
Nein, das weitet das Gesetz jetzt eben stark aus.
Weil es gab ja diese Gefahrenzonen, da wurde einem aber auch nicht,
also die waren festgelegt, aber die haben nicht gesagt, wo das ist, ne?
Ja, das gibt es auch. Gefahrenzonen waren nochmal so ein politisches Teil.
Und kriminalitätsbelastete Orte gab es auch, wo die Polizei sagt,
ja das ist jetzt ein kriminalitätsbelasteter Ort.
Und dann war da auch so solche Kontrollen möglich.
Aber es war relativ eingeschränkt und jetzt wurde schon viel Missbrauch getrieben
mit Kontrollen. Also eine Rechtsgrundlage zu kontrollieren, passiert natürlich auch.
Je weiter ich das ausdehne, desto größer wird der Missbrauch sein und desto
mehr Möglichkeiten hat die Polizei eben einfach so überall Menschen zu kontrollieren
und die Identität zu checken und so weiter.
Dabei kommt natürlich Beifang raus, dann kommt der Räwer aus dem Club und dann
hat er noch irgendwie irgendein halbes Pillchen dabei oder was auch immer.
Zack, habe ich viel Beifang. Das war interessant, da gab es über diese Bahnhofskontrollen,
ich weiß nicht, irgendeine Spiegel-TV.
Ich habe das auch auf YouTube geguckt.
Die haben ja kein einziges Messer gefunden, sondern immer nur und hier Gras
und den nächsten Jugendlichen rausgezogen. Und das ist halt so ein Ding,
du führst halt so ein Kontrollding ein, wo immer mehr Leute Angst haben müssen,
kontrolliert zu werden, die eigentlich nichts Böses im Schilde führen.
Zumal da diese Regeln, die sind ja auch, das ist ja schon wieder einige Zeit
her, dass bei der letzten Verschärfung, glaube ich, von diesen Waffengesetzen
wurden ja Messer verboten, die du mit einer Hand öffnen kannst. Ja.
Also die zeichnen sich üblicherweise dadurch aus, dass zum Beispiel an der Klinge
irgendwie ein kleiner Stift ist, den du dann mit dem Daumen drücken kannst und
kannst das Klappmesser öffnen. Oder mein...
Leatherman, den ich natürlich sofort vernichtet habe.
Leatherman ist auch super.
Der hatte auch eine Klinge, die man mit dem Daumen... Die habe ich natürlich
sofort abgegeben. Hier bei der Hisbollah-Waffensammelstelle oder was.
Leatherman ist jetzt verboten?
Naja, wenn es durchkommt.
Ist Leatherman auf jeden Fall verboten.
Naja, Moment. Der alte Leatherman Wave, der in Europa verkauft wurde.
Also Rettungssanitäter habe ich mir den geholt.
Der war nicht gut, der Wave.
Ja, das war aber nun mal der, den ich haben wollte. Gut, Tim. Alles klar.
Und den konntest du aber, unter anderem, deswegen habe ich ihn ja für den Rettungsdienst
geholt, mit einer Hand die Klinge rausfahren.
Und bei den damals, weißt du, bei den Rettungssanitätern, das ist lange her,
Tim, da warst du noch so alt, wie ich jetzt bin.
Und dann hast du, den konntest du halt mit einer Hand öffnen.
Das durfte man dann irgendwann nicht mehr.
Also ein solches Messer darfst du nicht mitführen.
Und das führte dann dazu, aber da konntest du noch eins mitführen,
wo du jetzt nach alter Väter Sitte du mit dem den Daumennagel abbrechen musst,
in so einer kleinen Kerbe um den Knie raus.
Und das ist jetzt auch nicht mehr. Das darf ich jetzt auch nicht mehr mithaben.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wie das mit dem Wandern dann geht. Oder wie das dann...
Also es ist auf jeden Fall...
Was ist mit meinem Kampfmesser am Stiefel?
Das ist auf jeden Fall...
Auch nicht mehr.
Also die Kritik bei der Anhörung.
Wo endet das? Darf man jetzt nicht später Fußgänger zu tun mit einer Machete rumlaufen oder was?
Doch, ne Machete.
Ne, es darf jetzt auch nicht mehr, dieses weiße Plastikmesser geht auch nicht.
Die Definition ist sehr weit jetzt.
Wie weißes Plastikmesser? Die von der Pommesbude?
Ja, genau.
Der ist ja eh verboten.
Ach, stimmt, diesen wegen Öko-Washing. Okay.
Genau, also das ist ein anderer Punkt dieses Gesetzes, ist dieses Änderung Waffengesetz,
Messer und, aber das Messerding ist eigentlich, ist mir erst eigentlich Wumpe,
was dabei rauskommt, ist anlasslose Kontrolle und da ist es eigentlich intensiv.
Dann gibt es noch, natürlich muss man zu einem ordentlichen Sicherheitspaket,
Überwachung gehört dazu, also es darf dann,
Biometrie, also Also quasi das, was sie bei dieser RAF-Fahndung irgendwie verkackt hatten,
quasi was sie nicht durften, dass sie dann jetzt irgendwie Bilder aus dem Internet
nehmen und das dann mit ihren Daten abgleichen, wenn sie jemanden suchen. Biometrie.
Quasi mit Referenzdaten, Internet und noch so.
Wobei bei der RAF-Sache könnte man jetzt auch fragen, wer da verkackt hat.
Eventuell war es auch Daniela Klette, die auf Facebook gelandet ist.
Aber je nachdem, wie man verkacken jetzt definiert.
Genau, also biometrische Überwachung nur Retrograd.
Das heißt also nicht in Echtzeit. Aber was heißt das, wenn ich drei Sekunden
später in Echtzeit mache, Daten aus dem Internet?
Dann ist es halt Retrograd, aber nicht in Echtzeit. Also da ist auch die Frage,
das wird sich beißen mit dem AI-Act.
Stimmt, das ist ja einfach mal ein Verstoß dagegen.
Ja, und DSGVO auch schwierig eigentlich, das jetzt so einfach zu machen und auszuweiten.
Und das nächste, was sie dazu kommen, ist, dass sie Datenbanken zusammenführen,
Big Data Anwendungen, bla.
Also nochmal so eine Datenbanken, mehr Datenbanken.
Und das alles, weil ein gestörter Mensch in, also ohne zwei,
also wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, hatten die den doch sogar schon mal
irgendwie auf dem Kieker, oder?
Die wollten den abschieben, haben den nicht abgeschoben, deswegen müssen jetzt
alle abgeschoben werden.
Also das ist so die Logik, so ein bisschen, na und ich meine okay,
über diese Terroranschlagnummer finde ich, also.
Du bist IS, wenn du ein Video machst und sagst, ich bin IS und dann bin ich
Terroranschlag. Wo ist der Unterschied?
Irgend so ein Typ, der irgendwie, also ich finde das eh schwierig,
diese Kategorisierung oder die Unterscheidung eigentlich. Nicht,
okay, das ist ein Amoklauf, ah, da war ja ein paar Tage später irgendwie eine
Deutsche, die mit dem Messer rumgemacht hat, dann ist es immer Amoklauf.
Aber das ist so niedrigschwellig, da kann ich so niedrigschwellig Terrorist werden.
Das ist natürlich auch das, was ISIS natürlich will, aber darauf zu zu reagieren
und zu dermaßen Grundrechte einzugreifen, ist halt total überzogen.
Und es wird dann auch null irgendwas bringen, um solche Anschläge...
Genau, so wie die Grenzkontrollen nichts bringen.
Also es ist einfach nur ein lautes...
Naja gut, man muss schon sagen, dass sich jetzt wahrscheinlich so ein Psychotiker
oder aus anderen Gründen zum Gewalttäter gewordener Mensch,
Mensch, schon nochmal zweimal überlegen wird, ob er jetzt mit dem Messer auf
andere losgeht, wenn Messer verboten ist.
Also da muss man schon auch mal sagen, dass da jetzt wirklich auch mit der Härte
des Gesetzes ganz klar, das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen, dass sie das weiterhin
machen, wenn man das jetzt verbietet.
Das hätte man schon viel früher mal verbieten sollen.
Ich war ja dort auch verboten. Sag das nicht zu ernst.
Sonst muss ich so ein E-Boot-Need-Dschingel einbauen.
Ich glaube, es war ja auf der Veranstaltung auch Messer schon verboten.
Ich glaube, es ist grundsätzlich sogar verboten, auf andere mit dem Messer loszugehen.
Ja, es wird nichts bringen. Also diese ganzen Verschärfungsmaßnahmen ist einfach
nur letztlich, würde ich sagen, ist eine...
Fortsetzung der AfD-Politik mit Ampelmitteln und wird uns nicht davor schützen,
dass irgendjemand sowas wieder machen können wird.
Also evidenzbasierte Sicherheitspolitik sieht anders aus.
Man könnte ja auch mal angucken, wo man diese Radikalisierung irgendwie stoppen
kann von so Leuten oder was da irgendwie Dinge sind.
Aber da zeitgleich Geld weg von solchen Programmen.
Glaube ich, gestrichen, die sich da um sowas kümmern. Also, ja.
Okay, aber erst mal mit dieser ganzen Messergeschichte sagst du,
da geht es eigentlich gar nicht um die Messer, sondern darum,
dass jetzt einfach kontrolliert werden kann, weil man immer sagen muss,
wir müssen gucken, dass wir kein Messer haben.
Ich kann jetzt quasi, also mit diesem Gesetz und wenn die Landesregierungen
das hart umsetzen und weite Dinge beschließen,
so wie das im Gesetz steht, was sie alles machen können, dann kannst du quasi
nicht mehr draußen dich bewegen, ohne in so eine Zone zu geraten und potenziell durchsucht zu werden.
Es gibt dann keinen Ort mehr, der eigentlich sicher ist vor einer anlasslosen Kontrolle.
Die Faschisten klopfen an die Tür, das ist ein geiles Gesetz auch.
Wenn ich alle überall kontrollieren kann, das ist so, wir machen das Haus schlüsselfertig
irgendwie, damit die AfD es übernehmen kann und dann auch gleich alle Gesetze hat.
Um mich, also das ist, sowas will man der Polizei nicht in die Hand geben und
es ist sogar vollkommen unnötig, weil es ist ein sicheres Land,
hier leben so viele rechtstreue Menschen, so viele Menschen,
die nichts Böses im Schilde führen und,
dann kann ich reinschauen, was sind das für Leute?
Und die Polizei wird, das werden dann noch andere Folgen, anlasslose Kontrollen.
Wenn man sich anschaut, gerade eine Studie rausgekommen, wo findet besonders viel Rassismus statt?
Bei der anlasslosen Kontrolle, bei Polizeikontrollen. Die Polizei kennt ihre
Pappenheimer und die Pappenheimer haben halt eine dunklere Hautfarbe oder sind
irgendeine Gruppe oder was sie gerade ihr Ziel ist,
dann sind es halt irgendwelche Leute mit schwarzen Pullovern oder Fußballfans
sind natürlich auch da prädestiniert.
Wer auch immer.
Das wird dazu führen, dass natürlich irgendwie der klassische Allmann weniger,
dem macht das nichts aus, der ist auch vielleicht dafür, das ist super, mehr Kontrolle.
Aber die Leute, die eh schon viel kontrolliert werden, werden noch mehr kontrolliert.
Und können dann auch überall kontrolliert werden mit Rechtsgrundlage.
Es ist ein Gesetz, das will man nicht haben und es wird uns keinen Gewinn an Sicherheit bringen.
Es gibt eine Sache, die mir bei diesen ganzen Kontrollen immer auffällt und
ich habe da jetzt sehr drauf gewartet, auch bei den Grenzkontrollen, das ist ja dann eine,
am Ende kriegst du eine absolute Statistik, du kriegst absolute Werte und wir
kennen das ja zum Beispiel.
Nach einem Musikfestival gibt es Verkehrskontrollen.
Und dann wird nicht gesagt, wie viele Kontrollen es waren, es wird nur gesagt,
keine Ahnung, da wurden zehn Leute mit Alkohol im Blut rausgezogen.
Und dann denkst du dir, meine Güte, unglaublich, haben die zehn Betrunkene,
die irgendwie in Schlangenlinien da weggefahren sind, davor bewahrt,
das nächste Kind umzuniehen.
Dass im Zweifelsfall aber tausend Fahrzeuge kontrolliert wurden und diese zehn
Leute Restalkohol hatten und dass du wahrscheinlich bei jeder anderen Kontrolle
von tausend Leuten, ohne dass irgendwo ein Musikfestival ist,
sei es mal ein Schützenfest, dass du da wahrscheinlich sehr viel krassere prozentuale
Ausbeute hättest, hörst du ja dann nicht.
Dann fangen die jetzt, da habe ich auch drauf gewartet, machen sie die Grenzkontrollen
und dann wird geguckt, okay, wie viele irregulären Migrationsvorgänge haben sie denn da jetzt?
Und dann natürlich, dann stellen die sich dahin, kontrollieren die Leute und
stellen dann Unregelmäßigkeiten fest.
In der Regel einfach keine, die jetzt irgendwie, also jetzt nicht 100 Leute
mit einem Messer davon abgehalten wurden, nach Solingen zu fahren, sondern irgendwelche.
Weiß der Geier, fährt einer ohne Ausweis über die Grenze oder ist in dem einen Land,
ansässig, weiß der Geier, aber nichts also, aber da kommen natürlich dann irre
Zahlen raus, wenn du an den gesamten deutschen Grenzen kontrollierst,
kommen natürlich, findest du da was. Also ist ja klar.
Und dann werden diese Zahlen berichtet und dann denkt man sich,
naja, meine Güte, das kann ja gar nicht sein.
Vor allem, wenn du nicht in Relation siehst zu, mehr oder weniger werden die
Grenzen nicht gemacht, kann keiner mehr drüber.
Und wir haben, weiß nicht wie viele tausend Polizistinnen damit zum Einsatz gekommen.
Wir haben so und so viele tausend LKWs verzögert.
Ich meine, das ist ja eh eine Frage, was für eine Sicherheit willst du eigentlich haben.
Also einen Großteil der Menschen schreckst du ab, es gibt ein Gesetz.
Und dann sind schon 95% der Leute sagen, okay, da mache ich nichts.
Auf welches Level von Delinquenz willst du eigentlich runtergehen?
Also wenn ich diese Kontrollen hochfahre, ich gehe nochmal zurück zu den Inlands anlasslos,
will ich jeden, also eine Gesellschaft, jeder Mensch, der einmal über Rot läuft,
der irgendwie, also will ich überhaupt so tief rein,
muss ich das überhaupt machen, ist das überhaupt nötig für eine Gesellschaft,
um sicher und einwandfrei zu funktionieren, dass ich quasi auf der niedrigsten
Ebene von Verstößen die halbe Pille von dem Raver, der Rotsünder,
der über eine Ampel läuft zu Fuß, was auch immer und dann jeden bestrafen.
Es reicht für die meisten aus, irgendwie Gesetze durchzusetzen,
dass es das Gesetz gibt und viele Leute bleiben dann rechtstreu und es reicht
aus, dass ich ab und zu Stichproben mache und Leute rausziehe,
um immer wieder den Schrecken der Strafe zu haben.
Wenn ich diese Strafe komplett hochziehe und das wird eine Gesellschaft,
die wird dann nicht besser und viel sicherer. Ich hole minimal was raus,
wenn überhaupt, treffe ganz viele Leute.
Wir müssen uns überlegen, in was für einer Gesellschaft wollen wir leben und
welche Art von Kontrolle ist überhaupt nötig, um sicher zusammenzusehen.
Deutschland ist eines der sichersten Länder der Welt.
Markus, du musst auch überlegen, man hört ja immer wieder, wie stark diese Pillen heutzutage sind.
Und wenn der Raver die halbe auch noch ballert, wer weiß, ob das nicht vielleicht
sogar zu viel ist. Und dann werden wir unsicherer in diesem Land.
Ich erinnere auch an die Diskussion, die wir ja hatten um rot überfahrende Autofahrer und so weiter.
Diese ganze Verkehrsdiskussion.
Ich hatte mir ja hier schon mal über diese Polizisten gesprochen.
Ich habe seitdem einfach mal fleißig weitergezählt, wie viele Radfahrer rechts
von mir, während ich im Auto oder auf dem Motorrad sitze, so über Rot fahren.
Das ist einfach eine geile Zahl.
Also wirklich jeden Tag zweistellig und ich will nicht, dass hier alle in den Knast kommen.
Ich war wieder kurz davor.
Naja, der Unterschied zum Autofahren ist ja der rotzündende Radfahrer.
Der Radfahrer wird ja dann überfahren und ist tot.
Nicht jedes Gesetz muss zwingend immer permanent überall zu jedem Zeitpunkt
angewendet werden, sondern es geht darum,
insgesamt einen Zustand herzustellen, in dem sich alle wohl und sicher fühlen.
Und wenn man sich anschaut, gerade bei dieser ganzen Terrorsache,
ich meine, in Russland, einem hochautoritären Staat, irgendwie schafft es ja
auch irgendeine islamistische Terrorgruppe in einem Oper, Theater,
Veranstaltungssaal.
Aber nicht mit einem Messer.
Sondern mit Es ist eh nicht möglich Eine absolut sichere Vollkommen sichere
Sache zu Generieren, deswegen müssen wir da gar nicht Sag es.
Sag den politischen Satz schlechthin.
Hundertprozentige Sicherheit Aber wir müssen ein Gleichgewicht Zwischen Sicherheit und Freiheit Okay.
Stopp Okay Noch ein Klassiker,
Wer Freiheit aufgibt, um Sicherheit zu erlangen, wird am Ende beides verlieren.
Das wissen wir auch noch.
Genau, vielleicht sollte man jetzt sagen, wie ging es jetzt mit diesem Gesetz weiter.
Also es kommt ein Gesetzentwurf relativ schnell nach dem Solingen-Attentat.
Und dann Bäm, erste Lesung Anfang September.
Dann elf Tage später Sachverständigenanhörung. Also es sind Gesetzespakete,
da könntest du für jeden der einzelnen Gesetzespunkte eine Sachverständigenanhörung
machen, so eingriffsstark sind die.
Sehr großes Tempo, die CDU sagt gar nichts mehr, weil sie überrascht ist, dass es so schnell geht.
Genau. Und jetzt passiert was Interessantes. Also die Grünen eher im Hintergrund,
waren nicht laut vorne, die FDP auch nicht so viel zu hören,
sondern aus der SPD brodelt es auf einmal.
Was ja bei Bürgerrechten eher nicht das Ding ist, aber es gab dann auf einmal
einen offenen Brief aus der SPD, die sagen, okay, diese Asylgesetzgebung, nee, das ist Quatsch.
Dann gab es die AG Migration in der SPD, die gesagt hat, nee,
das ist verfassungswidrig, das ist menschenunwürdig, nicht mit Werten der SPD vereinbar.
Auf einmal kommt Druck aus den Ampelparteien, also man muss sagen,
diese Gesetze werden von Frau Faeser, Bundesinnenministerin, vorangetrieben.
Und die waren ja auch, wenn man so knapp nach so einem Attentat Gesetzespakete
aus der Die lagen ja schon da. Genau. Die wollten immer schon Biometrie haben.
Biometrie abgleich mit. Also das wird dann einfach rausgeholt und dann gesagt
und dann wird das laut verkauft und interessant war schon,
dass eben die vermeintlichen Bürgerrechtsparteien FDP und Grüne da jetzt auf
einmal auch mit sagen, okay, das müssen wir jetzt machen. Das ist hier Zeitenwende angesagt.
Das ist ja jedes Lieblingswort. Und.
Ja, auf jeden Fall gab es jetzt dann doch Unstimmigkeiten in der Ampel, zum Glück.
Und das Ganze ist jetzt ein bisschen verlangsamt. Der Plan war erst,
das alles im September noch irgendwie durchzuprügeln, in einem Monat quasi.
Das wird jetzt nichts, zumindest. Das ist der 30. September, das hat nicht geklappt.
Wann kamen die mit diesen Gesetzen rein? Weil ich erinnere mich da an ein Transparent
beim Fußballspiel, was Tim und ich angeschaut haben.
Das war am 30. August.
Genau, also der Anschlag war am 23. August und dann gab es das Gesetz,
Moment, das muss ich auch mal schauen. Du kannst ja kurz schauen.
Ich lese dir mal das Fußballtransparent vor. Der Tim wird sich ja freuen,
wenn ich hier Transparente der Union Ultras Waldseite verlese.
Also zitieren. Heimliche Hausdurchsuchungen und Gesichtserkennungssoftware sich
im Ausland frei und demokratisch geben, doch zu Hause autokratische Fantasien ausleben.
Nancy Faeser, wer willst du sein? Sozi oder Stasi-Schwein? Stand da.
Grüße an die Waldseite.
Daran, dass ich das Foto gemacht habe, sieht man ja, dass ich da nicht nebengestanden habe.
Du hast dich etwa nicht solidarisiert?
Das sind ja immer Zäune bei euch da in dem Stadion, da kann man sich ja auch
nicht mehr freizufügen.
Also genau, es ist am 10., es ging auf jeden Fall sehr, sehr schnell. Also 23.
August war das Attentat, dann wurde es angekündigt, zwei, drei Tage später,
Peter, wir machen jetzt was,
in der ersten Septemberwoche im Bundeskabinett beschlossen, dann ging es in
die Ausschussanhörung,
die Anhörung am 23.
Und elf Tage davor war die erste Lesung im Bundestag.
Also es ging wirklich so Schlag auf Schlag. Und der Plan war eigentlich, dass im September.
Also man muss aber davon aus, wir wissen es ja bei den Biometrie-Sachen,
das gab es ja alles schon vorher.
Also es war einfach so ein klassischer Fall, du hast jetzt irgendeinen Vorfall
im Lande, dann darf man nicht vergessen, dass die CDU schon sehr rumgestresst hat.
Klar, und die Ampel wollte, also politisches Kalkül ist irgendwie,
okay, wir sind von der CDU unter Attacke, von der AfD sowieso unter Attacke
und jetzt machen wir irgendwas, was so hart ist.
Zum Beispiel grenzenlich, gute Idee, das wird, also nachdem jetzt alles nicht
geholfen hat, wird das ja jetzt wohl aber endgültig der AfD das Wasser abgraben, oder?
Also das ist ja wohl relativ klar, nachdem man jetzt… Naja.
Ich meine, das ist wirklich, also da kommen wir jetzt weit vom Netzpolitischen
weg, aber ich meine, wenn Martin Sellner sagt, guck, die machen jetzt schon
unsere Politik, wir müssen jetzt radikaler vorgehen, sonst haben wir nichts
mehr in der Tasche, quasi. Also so ähnlich war sein Tweet.
Und dann, finde ich, muss man sich vielleicht mal überlegen,
als Ampel, die als Fortschrittskoalition gestartet ist, ob man noch die richtige
Politik macht, wenn der Sellner sagt, die machen schon unsere Politik.
Also, und ob das die richtige Politik ist.
Sellner ist selber nicht mehr radikal genug.
Ja, also da muss man sich schon mal fragen, ob das irgendwie die richtige Variante
ist, deren Politik zu machen.
Anstatt evidenzbasierte Sicherheitspolitik und zu gucken, wie verhindere ich
denn, dass irgendwelche Menschen sich radikalisieren und dann Anschläge machen für ISIS.
Oder kann ich das mal erforschen, wie der Mechanismus da funktioniert und kann
ich dagegen überhaupt was tun? Also das ist, also ja.
Man könnte sich, also ich meine, du kannst ja nur, also du könntest zum Beispiel dich bemühen,
für Menschen, die dann schon mal hier sind, in irgendeiner Form Angebote der Integration zu machen.
Ich habe nicht den Eindruck, dass das, wie mit Asylbewerbern in diesem Land
umgegangen wird, geeignete Angebote der Integration sind.
Also so, das mag jetzt sein, dass das aus irgendwelchen Gründen,
also vielleicht überzeugt mich irgendjemand, dass wir die alle auf kleinstem
Raum zusammenfächern und von uns isolieren müssen, vielleicht gibt es da irgendeinen
guten Grund, für den mir bisher noch keiner erklären konnte,
aber zumindest erkennt man da jetzt nicht eine ausgestreckte Hand der Integration
und dann muss ich mich ja fragen, was machen die denn da?
Aber trotzdem, trotz dieser, sagen wir mal, Versuchen von den Leuten in Lager
zu stecken quasi und fernzuhalten von Integration,
ist es ja so, dass irgendwie, die Zahl fand ich wirklich geil,
dass von den Leuten, die zwischen 2014 und 2016 gekommen sind in der großen
Krise, von diesen jungen Männern sind heute 86 Prozent in Lohn und Brot.
Das ist mehr als die deutsche Bevölkerung.
Und das ist halt die Story, die nie von Migration erzählt wird.
Das ist ganz schön erfolgreich auch, obwohl wir da Probleme haben bei Integrationsmaßnahmen.
Und stattdessen packen wir noch
einen Tipp. Also es hat wieder nichts mit Netzpolitik zu tun, aber egal.
Stattdessen gibt es Land Berlin, das fand ich auch die geilste Geschichte,
Spiegelrecherche irgendwie,
gibt für Leute, die am Flughafen Tegeln, dem ehemaligen, die dort quasi sind
mehrere tausend Geflüchtete, sind dort interniert quasi in einem Lager.
Jeder dieser Menschen kostet 250 Euro am Tag.
Die geben alleine pro Insasse oder Lagerbewohnerin 1.500 Euro für Security aus.
Ich meine, du kannst die Leute im Ritz kalten für das Geld einmieten und mit
Frühstück am Bett. Aber das ist das Krasse.
Anstatt zu versuchen, die Leute in Wohnungen mit Integration,
mit Anschluss an die Bevölkerung, wird ein System erhalten,
in dem ich für ein horrendes Schweinegeld irgendwie Menschen in Waben,
in Zelten für 250 Euro am Tag irgendwie kaserniere, ohne Privatsphäre. Das ist doch Bullshit.
Das ist ja wie auf einem Feierfestival.
Nein, das ist wirklich, also das sind Fragen, die ich mir stellen muss,
wie kann ich eigentlich dieses System menschenwürdiger machen.
Okay, aber wollen wir weiter zu zu netzpolitischen Themen.
Aber diese Recherche, ihr müsst die wirklich lesen. Da versteht man die Welt
nicht mehr, wie sowas möglich sein kann.
Da muss auch Korruption im Spiel sein. Ich kann es mir nicht anders vorstellen. Das ist unglaublich.
Korruption vielleicht auf der einen Seite, aber auch so eine Unfähigkeit,
die Situation auch ausreichend zu reflektieren in ihrer Gesamtheit.
Da ist immer so ein Partikularblick und man spürt immer den Druck von irgendeiner Seite.
Auch man spürt so einen medialen und vor allem so einen Ein Stimmungsdruck,
der durch Medien vermittelt wird,
der durch soziale Medien vermittelt wird, der durch so eine aufgeheizte Debatte,
auch Talkshows und so weiter, die also die ganze Zeit immer,
alle leben nur von der Skandalisierung des Moments.
Und das ist natürlich eine sehr unglückliche Konstellation für uns alle.
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Und ich glaube, es lohnt aber auf jeden Fall auch zu gucken
in der ganzen Debatte, was läuft eigentlich richtig.
Ich glaube, dass wir uns da eh ganz schön verrennen als Gesellschaft,
wenn wir uns nur auf diese Migrationsthemen, also das ist einfach Quatsch.
Also ja, das ist einfach, okay.
Deswegen gehen wir jetzt zum nächsten Thema, Überwachungspaket.
Genau, im Oktober geht es auf jeden Fall weiter dort.
Mal gucken, was jetzt wie die schärfsten Zähne, also man kennt das ja,
dann werden die schärfsten Zähne gezogen und dann sagen die Grünen,
sie haben noch Bauchschmerzen und dann wird das irgendwie verabschiedet.
Keine Ahnung. Es ist aber auf jeden Fall interessant. Es gibt jetzt auf jeden Fall einen Gegenwind.
Und zig Bürgerrechtsorganisationen von Amnesty bis Sea-Watch haben gesagt,
das geht nicht, das Gesetz.
Die Zivilgesellschaft ist da irgendwie ganz schön alert und hat da gut gegen gefeuert.
Und nicht nur das. Ich meine, auch der Druck von unseren Nachbarländern ist natürlich groß.
Auf diese Rückschiebung.
Ja, also nicht nur die Rückschiebung, sondern auch einfach das übermäßige Kontrollieren der Grenzen.
Ja, ich meine, jetzt musst du wieder einen Reisepass mitnehmen irgendwie und sowas.
Die großen Errungenschaften Europas.
Völlig gar, gar. Ja, und vor allem, ich meine, das reduziert dann halt einfach
auch so den wirtschaftlichen und kulturellen Austausch einfach enorm und was
soll das? Also davon gewinnen wir gar nichts bei.
Das hatte ich jetzt so verstanden, ähm,
dass man das eigentlich auch gar nicht darf, Gemischengene Abkommen.
Also du darfst nicht dauerhaft Grenzkontrollen wieder einführen.
Das darfst du nicht nehmen.
Du kannst die einführen bei einer akuten Gefahr.
Ja, wie sowas, okay, wir haben jetzt hier G8-Gipfel, wir haben Fußball-WM irgendwie so.
Genau. Aber haben wir nicht gemacht.
Wir haben hier Fußball-WM und dann machen wir doch noch ein bisschen länger.
Das ist so, dass was passiert ist, oder?
Aber gab es bei der Fußball-EM hier Grenzkontrollen?
Ja, ja.
Ja?
Doch, doch.
Haben sie gemacht. Und dann haben sie die verlängert.
Also was mir übrigens auffällt, wenn ich mal was kritisieren darf,
diese Grenzkontrollen scheinen auch irgendwie nur da stattzufinden,
wo sie irgendwie nerven und in die Tagesschau kommen.
An Flughäfen habe ich das jetzt nicht festgestellt.
Also kann ich nicht, kann ich nicht.
Die Flughafen sind wahrscheinlich überwacht genug, um die Leute,
also das ganze System mit Fliegen ist ja schon so, dass die Fluglinien vorhinein
Leute, die kein Visa haben, nicht mitnehmen dürfen, sonst müssen sie zahlen.
Ja, aber wir reden doch hier von innereuropäischen Grenzkontrollen.
Ich habe diese in letzter Zeit, in diesem Monat mehrere innereuropäische Flüge gemacht, Ausland.
Nie irgendjemand nach meinem Ausweis gekommen. Ich habe extra meinen Pass mitgenommen,
weil ich dachte, boah, nicht, dass ich nachher hier wohin.
Also ich habe jetzt gerade einen Flug gebucht über ein Reisebüro und das wollte
jetzt Reisepassgruppinen noch sehen, um das korrekt einleiten zu können.
Also ich bin...
Was buchst du denn für einen innereuropäischen Flug über ein Reisebüro?
Hey, ich wusste nicht, dass du kein Internet hast.
Aber das hatte seine Gründe und auch gute, aber ist halt jetzt einfach mal so,
wie ich das geschildert habe und ich kann auch selber Flüge buchen,
aber das war eine nicht...
Kann dir das auch nochmal zeigen, wie das geht?
Ja, ich kann dir das nachher mal sagen, was das für eine Aufgabe war und ich
glaube, da würdest du auch dran scheitern.
Ich bin über mehrere Grenzen gefahren im Sommer. Und da gab es dann Grenzkontrollen.
Also die einzigen Grenzkontrollen, die es dann gab, waren von Deutschland raus
und nach Deutschland rein.
Nee, nach Deutschland rein. Raus standen sie nur so larifari-mäßig rum.
Da steht dann irgendwie so an der Autobahn und auf einmal wird es verengt.
Und dann stehen da so Jungsche Polizisten.
Und gucken kritisch, wer das Land verlässt.
Und gucken. Und wenn du so deutsch aussiehst, dann wirst du so durchgewunken quasi.
Das kam mir so vor. Also es war jetzt nicht, keine Ahnung, so Sichtkontrolle-mäßig.
Oder dann gucken, ist jemand hinten drin noch oder keine Ahnung.
Ich glaube, das ist auch so ein Ding, das ist auch sowas, um das rechte Narrativ
zu bedienen. Jetzt machen wir Grenzkontrollen, jetzt wird alles hier.
Also es ist alles so, man spielt in diesem Ding der AfD mit,
auch wenn es gar nichts bringt, wieder evidenzbasierte Sicherheitspolitik.
Das hat sich diese Koalition auch auf die Fahnen geschrieben,
auf die ampelfarbigen Fahnen.
Ein Koalitionsvertrag, aber okay, da stand auch drin, dass sie keine Biometrie
machen wollen und dass sie keine Vorratsdatenspeicherung machen wollen.
Da stand ja alles mögliche drin, was eigentlich ganz gut war und alle haben
gejubelt am Anfang und dachten, wow, cool, jetzt kommt so eine Bürgerrechtskoalition.
Zu früh gejubelt, passiert immer wieder. Aber es ist wie immer,
am Ende kommt immer der...
Das schwere Lohn der Grundrechtsfreundinnen und Freunde.
Jetzt...
Also zu den Kontrollen ist natürlich echt, also vor allem wenn sie,
wie du gerade schon sagst, Sichtkontrollen, die nicht nach zufälligen Prinzipien,
also erfolgen sie ja eh nicht,
also sei es eine Kontrolle auf dem Messer oder eine Kontrolle an der Grenze.
Ich würde mal vermuten irgendwie so ein schöner,
weißer Ukrainer der da irgendwo auf der Beifahrersitz sitzt,
hat eine sehr viel bessere Karten als ein,
nicht ganz so hellhäutiger in Deutschland zur Schule gegangener Mensch also
die haben natürlich alle auch eine,
und die Kontrollen nach Nach Messern natürlich genauso irgendwie eine Verzerrung,
die dann bei der Polizei auch stattfindet und die dann wiederum im Prinzip die
Bevölkerungsgruppen automatisch benachteiligt, bei denen man die Stereotype hat.
Also wenn ich davon ausgehen würde, jeder zehnte Mensch hat ein Messer dabei
und ich kontrolliere aber jetzt eine bestimmte Bevölkerungsgruppe öfter,
dann werde ich nachher in absoluten Zahlen sagen,
guck mal, bei denen alles für Messer weggenommen wird.
Das ist ja eh das Problem von polizeilicher Statistik, dass ich natürlich,
wenn mein Fokus ist, ich will Albaner kontrollieren oder was auch immer die
Polizei sich jetzt da vorgenommen hat, irgendwie quasi,
dann kriege ich nachher natürlich mehr Albaner, wenn ich sie treffe und wenn ich weiß, keine Ahnung.
Du musst ja nur gucken, wo die sind, dann stellst du dich halt dahin.
Ja genau, das ist polizeiliche Kriminalstatistik, das ist natürlich sehr viel,
was gucke ich, das bekomme ich auch und wenn ich jetzt die ganze Zeit Jugendliche
kontrolliere, dann geht natürlich auch die Jugendkriminalität hoch.
Jetzt haben wir gesagt Überwachungspaket, also wir haben jetzt über das Sicherheitspaket gesprochen.
Genau, Asyl und Überwachung, Antiterrorpaket, alles in einem,
also das Überwachungspaket.
Das macht was?
Das macht erleichterte Abschiebungen von Asylsuchenden, Biometrie bei Asylsuchenden,
Leistungskürzungen bei Asylsuchenden und so weiter.
Also Verschärfungen im Asylbereich, also die Leute, die trifft es am stärksten.
Was kann ich denn bei Asylsuchenden noch Leistungen kürzen?
Das ist das Ding mit dem, wenn jemand woanders schon Asylverfahren,
das kommt sehr häufig vor, die haben schon Asylverfahren laufen in einem anderen
EU-Staat und kommen dann nach Deutschland.
Dann sagt Deutschland, ja nee, kriegst hier kein Geld.
Das heißt, ich mache die Leute halt obdachlos oder die haben halt kein Geld.
Und das hilft sicher total gut gegen Kriminalität, wenn die Leute kein Geld
haben und so. Das ist also eine ganz super Maßnahme.
Es hilft auch natürlich gegen Messerangriffe ganz besonders stark.
Dann können sie ja keins mehr kaufen.
Ja, ja, genau. Also, äh,
Das ist so, also gegen Asylsuchende ist quasi ein Fokus. Das Gesetzespaket sind zwei Hauptgesetze.
Dann gegen Terror ist das andere.
Das ist eben quasi die Biometrie gegen alle anderen auch. Also nicht nur gegen Asylsuchende.
Gesichtserkennung, Stimmerkennung und das mit dem Internet abgleichen können.
Plus irgendwie Big-Data-Anwendungen bei der Polizei, so Palantir-Kram quasi.
Alles Sachen, die man eigentlich dachte, dass sie nicht kommen in der Ampel.
Plus eben diese Waffengesetzgebung, Messer jetzt irgendwie ausweiten bis zum
Ghetto und dadurch angebunden anlasslose Kontrollen überall,
die eben stigmatisierend sind, racial profiling etc.
Das ist so das im Groben das Überwachungspaket, was die Ampel als Fortschrittskoalition
bürgerrechtsfreundlich vorantreibt.
Wenn man jetzt so, wenn man sich wünschen möchte,
dass man Europa schadet und dem Zufriedenheits- und Sicherheitsgefühl der deutschen Bevölkerung,
dann würde man doch wahrscheinlich das gerade begrüßen, dass so etwas beschlossen wird, oder?
Also ich stelle mir jetzt gerade vor, in meiner letzten Sendung über die,
wie hieß diese russische Organisation? SDA, ne?
Social Design Agency.
Die Social Design Agency, der passt das doch jetzt, oder? Wenn da irgendwie, also man muss ja,
Also wenn jetzt die ganze Zeit von Polizisten kontrolliert wird auf Messer,
also auf mich hätte das einen Effekt, erstens würden die mich nerven,
aber da gewöhnt man sich dran.
Aber auf jeden Fall hätte ich dann natürlich auch irgendwie ein Gefühl davon,
dass es einen Anlass gibt, dass hier die ganze Zeit auf Messer kontrolliert werden muss.
Ja, das ist ja eh so ein Ding mit Polizeipräsenz, aber da gab es ja eine Studie,
ich weiß nicht, was, Uni Duisburg, nee, eine andere Uni, die hatten untersucht,
was heißt denn, wenn Polizeipräsenz hochgefahren wird, weil die sind immer in
der Politik gesagt, ja, wir haben ja viel Polizeipräsenz, da fühlen sich die Bürger sicherer.
Jetzt ist es so, dass man untersucht hat, was passiert denn,
wenn ich die Polizeipräsenz hochfahre, da fühlen sich die Bürger nämlich unsicherer,
weil sie denken, oh scheiße, irgendwas ist los, es muss irgendwas Schlimmes
sein, es ist hier voll gefährlich und fordern noch mehr Polizei und dann noch
mehr Präsenz und dann wird es noch gefährlicher.
Das ist auch Quatsch. Mehr Polizeipräsenz führt nicht dazu, dass das Sicherheitsgefühl,
das subjektive der Bürgerinnen und Bürger sich verbessert, sondern die denken
halt, es gibt einen Grund, dass so viel Polizei da sein muss.
Das muss irgendwas schief laufen hier.
Polizei ist ein weites Feld von Fehlentscheidungen, die man da treffen kann.
Möchtest du noch was zum Sicherheits- oder Antiterror- oder Überwachungspaket sagen?
Nee, ich glaube, zum Überwachungspaket kann man schon noch sagen,
wenn Leute sich dagegen einsetzen wollen,
ist es glaube ich gut, einfach Abgeordnete anzuschreiben aus der Ampel und zu
sagen, was ist denn da los, ich mach mir Sorgen.
Und Grundrechtseingriffe.
Es gibt die sehr gute Stellungnahme von der Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte
zu diesem Sicherheitspaket, wo eben diese ganzen Probleme dargestellt werden.
Und da ist, glaube ich, gut, den Druck zu machen, wenn man das jetzt irgendwie
als Bürgerin oder Bürger verhindern will.
Dann ist es auf jeden Fall sinnig, da nochmal jetzt einzugreifen.
Ja, und jetzt Chat-Kontrolle war das nächste Ding. Genau, also es reicht ja
nicht, dass nur in Deutschland die Überwachung hochgefahren wird,
sondern nee, wir brauchen das auch noch von EU-Seite.
Genau, und da gibt es ja seit zwei Jahren die sogenannte Chat-Kontrolle.
Hier sehr regelmäßig behandelt und verfolgt.
Viel von Khaleesi haben wir darüber gehört, von Thomas. Ja.
Und eigentlich hatte ich den Eindruck, dass diese Kuh doch jetzt vom Eis war.
Also ich muss sogar die ganze Zeit überlegen, was war denn jetzt der letzte Stand?
Also der Stand ist, wie weit wollen wir zurück?
EU-Kommission, Ilva Johansson sagt hier, unser Gesetz, die Verordnung gegen
sexualisierte Gewalt gegen Kinder,
das wird jetzt technologieoffen dazu führen, dass wir das bekämpfen.
So, jetzt kommt das Ding an. Was es beinhaltet, ist ein Scannen von,
also die sagen, wir machen eine Detektion von Dateien.
Das Ganze kann ich natürlich bei Verschlüsselung, das ist das große Problem,
kann ich diese Detektion halt nicht machen, wenn ich die Verschlüsselung habe.
Das heißt, ich muss die einzige technologische Methode, die EU beschreibt die
Technik aber nicht, die sagt, ja, irgendwie müsst ihr das hinkriegen,
Anbieter. Die Anbieter sind verpflichtet.
Kann ja nicht sein, dass Verschlüsselung hier auf einmal verschlüsselt.
Ja genau und dann sagen sie, wir gehen ja gar nicht an die Verschlüsselung,
sondern wir gehen vorher ran. Also ich fand das Bild ganz schön.
Also ich mache nicht den Briefumschlag auf, sondern ich stelle hinter den Briefeschreiber
eine Kamera und gucke, was er schreibt und dann ist das Briefgeheimnis ja gewahrt.
Das Briefgeheimnis ist gewahrt, sagt Frau Ilva Johansson.
Das ist so der, das Ding, das wird nicht anders gehen, als kleinseitig zu scannen.
Auf dem Endgerät zu gucken, ist da eine Datei.
So, jetzt hat es EU-mäßig, EU-Gesetzgebung hat das EU-Parlament hat gesagt,
das mit der Verschlüsselung, da wollen wir nicht ran.
Hat eine relativ vernünftige Position irgendwann beschlossen.
Und die Position ist fertig. Man muss dazu wissen, EU-Gesetzgebung funktioniert
so, das läuft, EU-Kommission macht Vorschlag, dann wird beraten im Parlament und beraten im Rat.
Rat ist quasi Quasi das föderale Element, wo die ganzen Minister,
die Länder drin sitzen. Kommission ist die Regierung.
Jetzt hat das Parlament seine Position und jetzt muss, wenn der Rat,
die EU-Kommission hat auch ihre Position, nämlich das, was sie eingebracht haben
und der Rat hat noch keine Position.
Und was jetzt passiert ist, ist, dass dieses Gesetz im Rat die ganze Zeit durchgefallen ist.
Die wollten es durchbringen und es gab immer eine Sperrminorität.
Es gab genug Staaten, unter anderem Deutschland, Österreich.
Oder die Regierungen gesagt haben, schickt da mal jemanden hin,
der sagt, naja komm, machen wir so nicht.
Ja genau, Deutschland war am Anfang ganz schwierig, weil die Fäser,
das Innenministerium verhandlungsführend, die wollte das natürlich haben und
wollte sich da nie dagegen aussprechen und wurde aber dann von der Ampel gezwungen
dazu quasi, dass sie jetzt dagegen ist und jetzt ist Deutschland dagegen.
Und jetzt musst du, wenn du eine bestimmte Anzahl von Millionen Einwohnern oder
einen bestimmten Prozentsatz, ich glaube 35 Prozent, dann hast du eine Sperrminorität.
Also wie die AfD in Sachsen.
Genau, dann geht ein Gesetz quasi nicht durch. Wenn jetzt genug Länder,
die genug Menschen repräsentieren, sagen, ah nee, da sind wir nicht dafür,
dann können die sich nicht einigen.
Jetzt war die erste Ratspräsidentschaft, die ist durchgefallen mit ihrem Ding,
dann kam die nächste, die hat dann gesagt, ja wir machen jetzt hier ein bisschen
Kompromissvorschlag, haben aber nichts geändert, nichts essentielles an dem
Ding, ist weiter durchgefallen.
Jetzt kamen die Ungarn, haben gesagt, wir machen noch mehr Kompromissvorschlag.
Aber das Essentielle nämlich das Scannen von irgendwie eigentlich geht es darum,
die Verschlüsselung da ranzukommen.
Kompromissvorschlag war ja irgendwie so,
als freiwillig aber wenn du dem nicht zustimmst, kannst du halt keine Bilder
und das war dann sogar das ist dann so ein Format von einem Kompromiss Das war.
Der eine Kompromiss, du darfst dann dein Signal benutzen, aber halt ohne Bilder und ohne Videos.
Wenn du nicht Chat-Kontrolle willst.
Ein anderer Ding ist, dass sie dann sowas gesagt haben, okay,
dann nehmen wir die Detektion nach neuen Inhalten raus,
was ja auch so eine geile False-Positive-Nummer ist, wenn ich nach neuen Inhalten
suche, wo ich dann nachher irgendwie, da reicht's aus, dann habe ich da ein
Prozent False-Positive und zwar viel mehr in den Tests.
Dann habe ich Millionen Menschen, werden der Polizei weitergeleitet als Kindesschänder.
0,0001.
Ja, es gibt so viele Nachrichten und Bilder, die verschickt werden.
Es ist eine totale Katastrophe.
Falsche Verdächtigung mit einer der verächtesten Straftaten geht auch nicht gut.
Das haben sie jetzt so rausgenommen. Dann die Detektion von Grooming.
Grooming ist quasi die Anbahnung von Kontakten von Erwachsenen,
die unter Vorgabe falscher Identität Minderjährige kontaktieren.
Die wollten sie auch automatisch detektieren, wie auch immer das gehen soll.
Ja, KI halt, ne? Aber die gute KI.
Das machen wir mit der KI jetzt.
Das machen wir jetzt mit der KI. Das ist jetzt raus, in dem ungarischen Vorschlag, aber...
Dieses Verschlüsselungsding ist halt noch drin. Also dieses Client-Side-Scanning.
Also dass ich auf dem Endgerät mir das anschaue, was die Leute da für Dateien verschicken.
Nur gegen eine Hash-Datenbank oder auch mit neuen Inhalten?
Nee, nur gegen eine Hash-Datenbank. Neue Inhalte nicht. Wir kennen uns raus. Bis es technisch geht.
Und ich meine, das Grundproblem an diesem ganzen Gesetz ist natürlich,
wenn ich irgendwie Bilder von CSAM, also Child Sexual Abuse Material,
genau, wenn ich danach suche, kann ich auch irgendwie nach Urheberrechtsdingern suchen.
Es ist ja nur eine Datenbank, die ich ändern muss. Und das ist ja auch das, was passieren wird.
Sobald das da ist.
Kommt die Urheberrechtslobby, dann kommen irgendwie, sagen, oh Terrorismus ist
auch eine gute Idee, dann kommt das Nächste, dann sagt China,
wie geil, Tiananmen, wollen wir auch nicht mehr sehen, dann kann ich nach allem suchen.
Egal was ich suche, das ist das Ende von Verschlüsselung.
Darum ging es auch, diese ganze Entstehung von dem, wir haben ja mittlerweile
250 Artikel darüber geschrieben, irgendwie die ganze Entstehung.
250 Artikel?
Ja, vielleicht 248, Aber es ist ja auf jeden Fall 250 Artikel.
Wir haben wirklich uns da reingenerdet bis ins Get-Know.
Und von Anfang an, da gab es die ersten Beratungen und da sitzt dann drin GCHQ
und Ding und lauter so Anti-Verschlüsselungs-Leute.
Das ganze Teil ist komplett gegen Verschlüsselung gerichtet.
Die Kinderschutzbünde sagen so, ey, ihr werdet keinen einzigen Missbrauch irgendwie
verhindern, weil darum geht es dabei. Ihr wollt halt Dateien finden.
Ich meine, das ist ja auch ein Ding. Die reden immer, ja, wir schützen, wir retten Kinder.
Ja, geht so. Das ist halt der Dreiklang, um Überwachung einzuführen.
Ich erinnere mich da noch sehr gut dran. Das war ein Paper-Dreiklang.
Wo Leute, da war GCHQ und sonstige Leute daran beteiligt, wo es darum ging,
sag doch mal, wie es geht.
Mach doch mal bitte sieben Methoden, vergleich die mal und dann sag mal,
welche irgendwie noch so die beste wäre.
Unterwahrung natürlich irgendwie von irgendwelchen Privatsphären.
Und dann kam nämlich raus, dann haben sie da sieben Methoden verglichen.
Unter anderem, ja wir könnten natürlich das komplette Telefon trojanisieren
oder mit irgendwelchen völlig absurden Dingern oder wir könnten Verschlüsselung
abschaffen und in dem Reigen war dann so, ja okay, wir scannen,
auf der Plattformform Verschlüsseln, das war dann, da erschien da auf einmal
was Sinnvolles also erschien dann noch so die mildeste Maßnahme aber dass man
einfach mal sagt so, ja vielleicht,
suchen wir hier auch an der falschen Stelle oder lösen das Problem nicht da, wo es wirklich ist.
Da hat natürlich keiner sich Gedanken.
Das ist ja genau der Punkt und ich glaube, das wird bei dem ganzen Thema natürlich,
das ist wieder sowas mit schnell, man hat irgendwie Sicherheitspolitik wieder
evidenzbasiert, irgendwie funktioniert es eigentlich nicht, weil eigentlich
wenn ich Grooming verhindern will, dann gehe ich in die Schule und bringe den Kindern bei,
wie Grooming funktioniert und warum sie aufpassen sollen, wenn da irgendjemand
kommt, den sie vielleicht nicht kennen. und so weiter. Das kann ich lernen.
Da kann ich Präventionsprogramme machen. Das gibt's auch schon in Schulen auch.
Aber es gibt einfach viel bessere Methoden. Oder wenn ich irgendwie gucken will,
dann mache ich gute Meldemechanismen. Oder was auch immer.
Es gibt so viele Sachen, die man tun kann.
Ja. Aber es geht halt nicht darum eigentlich, also es geht vordergründig darum.
Das ist schon, ja, es geht vordergründig darum und also erkennbar ist die Maßnahme nicht geeignet.
Ist nicht geeignet und sie wird, ja, also sie richtet sich gegen Verschlüsselung,
es wird ausgeweitet werden, wenn es mal da ist und die jetzt,
ja und das Ganze war ja begleitet von riesigen Lobbykämpfen mit Ashton Kutcher
und der eine Firma hat und dann irgendwie,
ja, also jetzt, ja, okay, 250 Artikel könnt ihr alle nachlesen,
Hashtag Chatkontrolle.
Oder hier nachhören. Ich vermute, dass wir die alle inhaltlich auch behandeln können.
Jetzt steht also das Ding am 10.
Oktober auf der Tagesordnung des Ausschusses der Ständigen.
Am 2.
Also es steht jetzt erstmal im, es steht jetzt erstmal.
Achso jetzt, Moment, am 2. kommen die ständigen Vertreter. Am Mittwoch. Und am 10.
Treffen sich dann die Ministerinnen. Ach das waren die, ja die hatten wir auch
schon mal. Wie hießen die mal sowieso, Reps? Die werden.
Co-Repper. Achso die Repre, genau.
Dieses ständige Vertreter.
Ständige Vertreter, genau. Jetzt kommt das erste Ding, ist jetzt,
die haben das jetzt mehrfach irgendwie versucht und sind immer gescheitert und
ziehen das dann von der Tagesordnung zurück.
Also der letzte Versuch, da haben sie gemerkt, oh, wir kriegen die Zustimmung
nicht, dann stimmen sie es gar nicht ab, weil sie möchten nicht die Niederlage sehen.
Also fragen sie so, wie ist denn die Zustimmung und dann merken sie,
ah, ist nicht, dann nehmen sie es von der Tagesordnung. Jetzt ist es auf der
Tagesordnung wieder drauf und wenn es da durchkommt, dann wird es am 10.
Im Justiz und wenn es da dann durchkommt, dann ist die Position des Rates fest.
Das heißt, das Problem ist jetzt in diesen Trilogverhandlungen,
wir haben jetzt die gute Position des Europaparlaments, also die ist relativ
okay, weil sie eben Verschlüsselung schützt.
Und jetzt kommt eine Position von dem Rat und wenn das jetzt dann nicht drin
ist, dann stehen nachher Rat und EU-Kommission,
die beide die harte Nummer wollen dann, gegen das Parlament und in diesem Trilogverfahren
wird sich das Parlament dann nicht mit seiner Position durchsetzen können.
Diese Trilog-Verfahren ist eh so ein bisschen intransparenter Prozess.
Und das ist das Problem. Das heißt, wenn jetzt die Verschlüsselung im Rad nicht
geschützt wird, wird es hart, die noch wegzubekommen.
Bis dann das Gesetz. Und dann haben wir den Salat. Das ist die Situation.
Und es sah jetzt die ganze Zeit immer gut aus und immer wieder geschafft irgendwie,
dass das nicht durchkommt.
Aber das sind halt so Zombies. Also ich meine, das ist, diese Dinger,
die kommen halt immer wieder. Und die versuchen so lange, bis es irgendwann klappt.
Also die kriegst du nicht tot. Dann gewinnst du eine Schlacht und denkst dir,
geil. Ich hab ihn, und dann...
Kommt der Nächste.
Vor allem, weil du auch nicht über so lange Zeit diese...
Ich meine, bei der Chatkontrolle, wie viele Wissenschaftlerinnen und die,
sogar die Juristin, der juristische Beirat des EU-Rates und hier.
Und selbst in der EU-Kommission waren sie dem Ding am Werk zu gehen.
Also, zu breit habe ich selten gesehen, dass eine Ablehnung von einem Projekt
ist, von einem Wo Leute sagen, hey, das ist gefährlich.
Das ist gefährlich für IT-Security, das ist gefährlich wegen falschen Verdächtigungen
und False Positives, das ist gefährlich wegen anlasslosen Überwachung,
die Privatsphäre, Verschlüsselung brechen.
Das ist aus so vielen Gründen scheiße, das Gesetz.
Und das wird einfach dazu führen, mal gucken. Also, wie gesagt,
die Hoffnung noch nicht aufgeben, die Sperrminorität wackelt,
es kommt jetzt so ein bisschen auf die Niederlande drauf an,
wie die jetzt noch steht, wenn die fällt, weil die Franzosen sind gefallen. So.
Welche Rolle spielt denn Ungarn mit seiner Ratspräsidentschaft?
Die wollen es natürlich super, mehr Bewachung und da einen Kampf gegen Kinderpornografie.
Das steht ja vollkommen außer Frage. Ich frage mich halt nur,
wie sehr Ungarn jetzt eigentlich in Anführungsstrichen ernst genommen wird von den anderen.
Offensichtlich wird es ernst genug genommen.
Na gut, also für die Hardliner ist es natürlich dann sozusagen easy.
So, ja. Ja, ist doof, aber...
Ja, wir haben jetzt auch ein neues Parlament und das ist natürlich ein großer
Rechtsruck bei der Europawahl passiert. Das ist nicht unbedingt gut für...
Da wissen wir auch gar nicht, wie sich das so auswirken wird.
Ja, das ist auch nicht gut für... Also für Grundrechte und Freiheitsrechte ist
ein Rechtsruck immer schlecht.
Ja, also wird hart. Mal gucken, wie es ausgeht am Mittwoch und das Ganze sie,
würde es dann noch ein bisschen begleiten.
Ja, die Hoffnung war natürlich schon mal größer. Ich dachte eigentlich so,
okay, vielleicht ist es da irgendwas irgendwie vom Tisch, aber ja.
Das ist schon sehr ernüchternd, weil man ja zwischendurch echt gedacht hat,
naja, jetzt haben wir das langsam echt mal hinter uns, ne.
Ja, aber es ist gegen alle Vernunft so, dass es mich so fertig macht.
Es geht einfach darum, die Verschlüsselung wollen wir brechen,
da haben wir keinen Bock mehr drauf auf Verschlüsselung und deswegen wird das gemacht halt.
Also das ist das Learning daraus.
Es geht einfach darum, da einen Fuß in die Tür zu kriegen.
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Und es ist schon auch klar, warum. Oder es war immer klar,
dass das passieren würde.
Aber die Frage ist, an wen richtet sich denn am Ende diese Verpflichtung?
Weil, also ich würde davon ausgehen, dass es ja eine Abwanderung geben wird.
Also wir haben ja jetzt beispielsweise Signal und Threema, die haben ja glaube
ich schon gesagt, pass auf, bevor wir das machen, lassen wir das eben sein.
Dann gehen wir nicht mehr.
Sogar WhatsApp. In England gibt es ein ähnliches Gesetz, wo sie dann nach der
Verschlüsselung auch rausgenommen haben. Erstmal.
Weil die auch gesagt haben, dann gehen wir. Aber mal gucken,
was dann passiert. Dann wird es spannend. Dann sagt Signal, wir machen da nicht mit.
Dann wird Signal aus dem App Store genommen wahrscheinlich.
Dann machen die Druck. Dann sagen die, okay, Signal ist eine unerwünschte App.
Dann kann ich die auf dem iPhone auf jeden Fall nicht mehr laden.
Mit Android dürfte es noch funktionieren. Dann kann ich natürlich irgendwie technisch ausweichen.
Aber ich meine, das Problem ist ja immer, wenn ich so eine Massenüberwachung
hochziehe, dass ich für die Nerds und Hörerinnen von Logbuch-Netzpolitik wird
es nicht das große Problem sein, noch weiter verschlüsselt zu kommunizieren
erstmal, bis dann die VPNs verboten werden. Aber okay.
Also aber du schaffst am Ende eine Massenüberwachung für den Großteil.
Also die Generation meiner Eltern wird dann irgendwie Schwierigkeiten haben
oder irgendwie wie ein Haufen Leute und dann hast du halt, die 90% der Leute hängen dann halt drin.
Das ja sowieso, also die Überwachung fast immer nur diejenigen,
die es nicht schaffen, die zu umgehen, aber jetzt darf man auch nicht vergessen,
dass es überhaupt Signal in dem Ausmaß gibt und dass WhatsApp in der Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung,
ausgerollt haben, ist eine Snowden-Folge.
Snowden war 2013, also vor elf Jahren. So, jetzt...
Könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass eine neue Bewegung stattfindet.
Also allein, wenn jetzt angenommen Signal und Threema gehen,
dann werden alle Leute, die das benutzen, sich was Neues suchen müssen.
Und die werden sicherlich nicht sagen, naja okay, wenn die wegen Verschlüsselung
brechender Massenüberwachung den Dienst einstellen, dann gehe ich jetzt eben zu WhatsApp.
Ja, dann werden die Leute ja schon, die werden potenziell.
Ja, wir wollen Verschlüsselung weiterhaben. Ich will eine Verschlüsselung haben.
Ich habe keinen Bock drauf, unverschlüsselt. Oder quasi mit...
Für wen gilt denn dieses Chat-Kontrolle-Anforderung?
Interpersonale Kommunikation.
Naja, aber für die Anbieter? Anbieter.
Keine Ahnung, wie das genau dann laufen wird.
Eine normale Chat-App, die Jabba, Matrix oder sonst was Client ist und nicht
an einen Anbieter gebunden ist, wird die sich dem entziehen können?
Das weiß ich noch nicht. Also das richtet sich an Anbieter.
Ich kenne jetzt noch keine Größengrenzen oder ob das jetzt kommerziell...
Das wird ja jetzt in die Föderation führen.
Oder wenn ich jetzt, sagen wir mal, ich biete jetzt einen Matrix-Client an,
der hat dieses Feature nicht.
Wenn ich jetzt kein Unternehmen da hinten dran habe und einfach nur eine App,
die quasi dezentral das alles macht und...
Das geht alles demnächst ins Fediversum hier. Das wird alles äh...
Mit PGP über Matrix gemacht dann.
Ach Gott, du willst eine Messenger-Diskussion?
Nein, es geht auch glaube ich gar nicht, also ich habe da jetzt gerade kurz von abge...
Es geht nicht darum, ob irgendein Linus, Markus, Tim und die Hörerinnen und
Hörer von Logbuch Netzpolitik irgendeine Lösung finden, wie wir das umgehen.
Es geht darum, dass für den Großteil der Bevölkerung diese Überwachung dann ausgerollt wird.
Die wird ausgerollt und die wird nach dem, Function Creep heißt das Phänomen,
Function Creep heißt, ist eine technische Lösung da?
Also zu deutsch, Function Creep ist, wo ein Trog, da kommen die Schweine,
so ist eine Lösung da, dann wird sie auch ausgeweitet werden.
Und das wird natürlich, wenn ich sowas im großen Stil ausrolle,
dann kommt die Technologie, dieses Zeug auf den Handys, dann werden sich die
autoritären Systeme dieser Welt die Hände lecken, das geil europaweit, wird das ausgerollt.
Hände lecken sagt man nicht, die Hände reiben und die.
Die lecken sich sogar um die Hände.
Die lecken sich um die Hände, vor Freude die Hände lecken. Das ist natürlich,
das ist der Traum von Überwachung, wenn ich quasi alles durchsuchen kann.
Und das wird vom Europa aus gemacht. Dann kann ich schon sagen,
ja guck die Europäer machen es ja auch.
Und dann wird die Infrastruktur dafür geschaffen werden und dann gibt es das
alles und dann mache ich einfach meine Datenbank da rein und dann habe ich das, kann ich alles.
Es ist sowas von wahnsinnig, dieses Gesetz zu wollen, diese Verordnung.
Okay, wir sind dagegen. Wir müssen uns jetzt.
Wir können jetzt wenig machen, wir können jetzt nicht irgendwie,
ja, ich weiß nicht, wieder Leute, Regierungen anrufen. Das geht ja auch nicht.
Also Deutschland steht jetzt da, die haben sich ziemlich festgelegt und hoffentlich
nicht jetzt unter dem Eindruck von Solingen, kippen die jetzt nicht um.
Die Deutschland wird da nicht kippen.
Nicht, dass dann nachher Messerbilder verschickt werden über den Messenger oder so.
Messenger.
Boah.
Die hast du gar nicht mehr mithaben.
Die Wortwitze. Lass sie nach. Das so früh am Morgen.
Es ist etwas passiert. Da wurde auch mit dem Messer etwas gekappt.
Das dürfen wir demnächst auch nicht mehr machen.
Wir haben über den Streit zwischen der Deutschen Telekom und Facebook berichtet,
hinsichtlich ihres Peering- bzw. Transitabkommens.
Also, die nennen sich ja jetzt frecherweise Meta.
Ja, man muss ja nicht alles mitmachen.
Das stimmt. Wir sagen ja auch noch Twitter. Alter...
Also...
Also der Hintergrund war, es gibt Internet-Exchanges, die sogenannten Kixe,
an denen knoten sich Leute, die mit dem Internet verbunden sein wollen, zusammen.
Und es gibt dann Facebook, die sehr sehr viel Datentraffic in diesem Internet
ausmachen und da gab es eigene Netzübergabepunkte,
die Facebook und die Deutsche Telekom miteinander errichtet hatten und für deren
Nutzung hat die Deutsche Telekom Rechnungen geschrieben.
Irgendwann hat Facebook, anfangs haben sie gezahlt und irgendwann hat Facebook
gesagt, das machen wir jetzt nicht mehr mit, wir zahlen jetzt hier nicht mehr.
Dann hat die Deutsche Telekom gesagt, ihr müsst aber bezahlen,
weil sie Verträge hatten, wurde Facebook auch dazu verurteilt,
dafür zu bezahlen, diese Dinger in Anspruch zu nehmen, für die sie ja vorher
auch bezahlt hatten und die waren sich da ja irgendwann mal handelseinig.
Und jetzt war klar, das eskaliert nach langsam und jetzt war die nächste Frage
ja, was ist denn jetzt nach diesem Urteil?
Weil Facebook war ja jetzt verurteilt für diese Leistung zu zahlen,
sie sind aber natürlich nicht verurteilt worden, diese Leistung in Anspruch zu nehmen.
Und ich hatte ja vor einigen Wochen schon mir so vorgestellt,
wie da jetzt die Deutsche Telekom und Meta, Facebook,
am Tisch sitzen und versuchen, sich zu einigen.
Und jetzt passierte am 25.
September folgendes, Meta veröffentlicht einen Blogpost und irgendwie zeitlich
die Deutsche Telekom auch,
ich mach mal erstmal Metas Seite, warum wir unsere direkte Peering-Partnerschaft
mit der Deutschen Telekom beenden müssen.
Und sagten also hier Gerichtsentscheid so, nach monatelangen Gesprächen sind
wir überrascht und enttäuscht über das Scheitern der Verhandlungen mit der Deutschen
Telekom. Das ist natürlich auch eine interessante Verhandlung,
wenn du sagst, wir geben euch kein Geld mehr.
Die Verhandlungen scheitern bei mir auch regelmäßig. Aber okay.
Wir haben in Deutschland und weltweit unentgeltliche Peering-Vereinbarungen
mit Telekommunikationsanbietern, die ihren NutzerInnen einen qualitativ hochwertigen
und schnellen Zugang zu unseren Apps ermöglichen.
Jede und jeder sollten von dem offenen Internet profitieren.
Meta wird weiterhin alles in seiner Macht Stehende tun, um einen qualitativ
hochwertigen Zugang zu seinen Apps aufrechtzuerhalten und die Menschen miteinander
zu verbinden. Was ist denn jetzt passiert?
Tja, Meta hat gesagt, okay, wir werden das jetzt nicht mehr über diese Dedicated-Verbindung
machen, sondern wir nutzen …,
Einen Transit-Anbieter. Also da werden sie mit Sicherheit auch für bezahlen.
Irgendjemand wird sich da die Finger reiben.
Aber die zanken ja beide darüber, ist das jetzt Peering oder Transit.
Transit und Meta steht auf der Wahrnehmung näher, das ist Peering,
Settlement Free, wir haben beide ein Interesse an dieser Verbindung,
also halten wir sie beide nach bestem Wissen und Gewissen aufrecht und die Deutsche Telekom sagt,
nö, wir betrachten das als Transit,
weil ihr ja unsere Netze nur nutzt, um woanders hinzukommen,
nämlich zu unseren Kunden.
Und deswegen wollen wir dafür gerne einen Taler haben. So.
Jetzt gucken wir uns also damit ist glaube ich jetzt die Perspektive von Meta klargestellt.
Gleichzeitig ist natürlich auch klar, Meta möchte natürlich jetzt auch nicht
eine Situation schaffen, in
der sie auf einmal von allen Internetanbietern zur Kasse gebeten werden.
Also wollen sie jetzt hier natürlich irgendwie auch eine Präzedenz schaffen.
Wichtig ist aber, ich bin mir sehr sicher, dass sie jetzt einen Transit-Anbieter
nutzen und ich bin mir nicht so sicher, ob der billiger ist als das Angebot,
was die Telekom ihnen gemacht hatte. Das weiß ich nicht.
Ich kann mir nur vorstellen, wer auch, also die kommen jetzt über Transit, dieser Anbieter,
Wer auch immer den jetzt Transit gibt, hat wahrscheinlich nicht so viel Überschusskapazität
gehabt, dass er sagen kann, ach so, Facebook nehmen wir noch mit da drauf,
ja sicher, patch mal durch.
Also da würde mich wundern.
Verständnisfrage.
Wozu brauchen die jetzt einen Transit-Anbieter? Können die sich nicht einfach
ans ZIX, ans DE-ZIX begeben?
Ist ja sogar sehr gut möglich, dass sie das tun. Also das, klar.
Also dieser Transit-Anbieter kann sozusagen das ZIX sein. Das meinst du damit?
Ja, also aber irgendjemand muss ja da auch sein. Also irgendwo kommst du ja auch zu dem KIX hin.
Ja. So und nach meinem Verständnis ist ja die Idee der Deutschen Telekom,
dass sie einfach an den KIXen halt so...
Und man zahlt, wenn man am DE-ZIX ist, sagt man ZIX oder KIX.
Der Klaus Landefeld, der bei uns in der Sendung war, hat gesagt Kicks.
Weil es ja Commercial Internet Exchange heißt.
Ja, aber irgendwie so eine Abkürzung entwickelt doch ihr eigenes Leben.
Also ich weiß nicht, ich finde Zicks.
Jif, it's pronounced Jif.
Ich kann nicht D-Kicks sagen. D-Kicks klingt falsch.
Ich wollte es jetzt extra mal richtig sagen.
Es gibt kein richtiges und falsches. Wenn.
Die Jifs am D-Zicks.
Also jetzt dann wichtig ist.
Nicht nur den Message an den Richtigen, sondern wie man sagt auch noch in den
Kommentaren an Tim zu dem Tipp zu dem Ja.
Mir egal. D6. So, also wenn jetzt die da D6 anlanden, dann zahlen die ja dem
D6 Geld dafür, dass sie dort sein dürfen.
Also ich meine, die dienen ja damit Geld, dass sozusagen Firmen dort landen und dort austauschen.
Nur der Traffic als solcher, der dann über das D6 geht, geht halt zu allen Also
man hat zwar Präsenzkosten, aber man zahlt nicht im eigentlichen Sinne für die Daten.
Also das ist mein Verständnis der Situation. Ich bin wirklich nicht mehr sehr
tief in dieser ganzen Transitwelt drin, aber das ist jetzt zumindest das,
was ich erwarten würde, weil sie werden ja jetzt nicht irgendeine andere Firma nehmen,
die dann einfach eins zu eins ihre Daten dann bei der Telekom anlandet und sagt,
hier nimm mal, weil jetzt ist es ja nicht mehr von Meta, es sind aber auch dieselben Daten.
Aber ist das nicht eh der Versuch, also Gott, ich kenne mich ja auch nicht,
das ist so ein typisches Thomas-Rudel-Thema.
Ist das nicht aber so, dass diese ganzen Telekommunikationsanbieter wollen doch
eh irgendwie mitverdienen? Die kriegen selber, haben sie halt kein Content.
Ja, die wollen doppelt.
Ich verkaufe dem Kunde für x Euro einen Anschluss und jetzt sage ich nochmal
zu Meta, na wenn ihr hier rein wollt, dann müsst ihr auch nochmal zahlen.
Also ich dachte, dass die Leitung
jetzt, wenn sie einmal der Kunde bezahlt hat, eigentlich ausreicht?
Das ist das Taxi, was sozusagen von dem Restaurant auch noch Kohle haben will,
dass es da Gäste hinfährt.
Vielleicht kurz schauen wir uns die Position der Deutschen Telekom an.
Die Deutsche Telekom sagt, wir hatten hier eine direkte Peering-Verbindung,
für die wir Transitgebühren verlangt haben und die hören jetzt einfach auf und
nutzen jetzt einen anderen Transitanbieter. Das sagt die Telekom sogar selber.
Um die rechtmäßigen Zahlungen dennoch zu vermeiden, hat Meta entschieden,
seine Datenverkehre statt wie bislang über den direkten Weg nunmehr über einen
Transit-Anbieter ins Netz der Telekom zu leiten. Was völlig in Ordnung ist.
Solange der Transit-Anbieter in der Lage ist, diese Leistung der Deutschen Telekom
anzubieten, ist das völlig in Ordnung.
Mein Traffic kommt ja auch über den Transit-Anbieter hin. Bei mir haben die
sich auch noch nicht beklagt.
Verhandlungen zu weiteren direkten Zusammenschaltungen hat Meta scheitern lassen.
Für die neuen Übergabepunkte hat die Deutsche Telekom ihre Kapazitäten mit dem
von Meta genutzten Transit-Provider mehr als ausreichend ausgebaut.
Auch völlig in Ordnung, musst du ja. Also ich gehe mal davon aus,
dass weder der Transit-Anbieter noch die Deutsche Telekom genug Kapazität hatten,
um mal eben Facebook zu klären.
Wie viel Facebook an Traffic macht ins deutsche Telekom-Netz,
schreibt die Telekom zum Glück auch und sagt, für die großen Datenmengen Metas,
das Unternehmen speist gigantische 3,5 Terabyte in das Netz der Telekom,
was etwa 100.000 HD-Filmen entspricht und das alles pro Sekunde.
Hat die Telekom damit alles in ihrer Macht stehende für einen reibungslosen Datenverkehr getan.
3,5 Terabyte pro Sekunde.
Das ist ganz viel.
Da brauchst du ein richtiges Kabel für. So. Und jetzt kommt die...
Und jetzt beklagt sich die Deutsche Telekom und sagt, in der direkten Zusammenschaltung
hatten wir die Kapazitäten nicht.
Wir haben die jetzt bei dem Transit-Provider, der sicherlich dafür Geld kriegen wird.
Der berechnet ja Transit-Gebühren. Der reibt sich jetzt gerade die Hände und
sagt, Super, muss jemand bezahlen, Meta nämlich.
Es liegt nun in der Verhandlung, jetzt sagt die Deutsche Telekom,
ja, aber jetzt muss Meta diese Kapazitäten, die wir an den Transit-Provider
geben, auch störungsfrei routen.
Meta entscheidet selber, wie der Verkehr in das Netz der Deutschen Telekom geleitet
wird. Auch das ist richtig, das ist Metas gutes Recht.
Und der Beginn der Umleitung der Datenverkehre in der Nacht von Dienstag auf
Mittwoch ist reibungslos erfolgt.
Und bis jetzt erscheint mir das alles nach der freien Markt-
Macht so, die freie Hand des Marktes führt dazu, dass Meta sich,
die unsichtbare Hand des Marktes
reguliert den Preis. Ja, sie erscheint eigentlich völlig in Ordnung.
Jetzt gibt es aber, an dieser Stelle fehlt mir jetzt auf einmal etwas in dem
Telekom-Blogpost und glücklicherweise habe ich von Thomas eine Archive-Version
des ursprünglichen Telekom-Blogposts gefunden.
Der ging nämlich dann noch etwas interessanter weiter, wo dann nämlich drin steht,
naja, Meta ist ja nicht über dem Gesetz und unglücklicherweise folgt,
ich übersetze jetzt aus dem englischen Teil, unglücklicherweise folgt Metas
Verhalten hier einem Muster.
Meta versucht, in Europa Steuern zu vermeiden.
Meta ignoriert den europäischen Datenschutz via WhatsApp.
Meta versucht, die Nutzer in Zahlungsmodelle zu zwingen,
die Consumer Protection Laws, Verbraucherschutzgesetze nicht beachten.
Meta lügt die Öffentlichkeit an
über Hate Speech und Meta hat Cambridge Analytica Daten gegeben und damit indirekt
Wahlen beeinflusst also hier nimmt dieser Blogpost echt so einen Weg der jetzt
nur noch sehr wenig mit Transit zu tun hat ja weil anfangs wird beschrieben Moment mal,
die nützen jetzt jemand anders, ist alles völlig in Ordnung die bezahlen den auch Das hat.
In Meta dann irgendwie rausgeklagt.
Mit verboten oder was?
Oder irgendjemand hat ihnen gesagt, dass das keine gute Idee war. Das ist eine gute Idee.
Beleidigt den Lebewusstsein halt. Du, wenn halt das echt ein bisschen.
Da habt ihr euch ein bisschen verhoben. Aber jetzt, da steht jetzt noch so ähm,
Anstatt das Urteil eines unabhängigen deutschen Gerichts zu akzeptieren,
spielt Meta jetzt ein grobes Foul.
Die Deutsche Telekom wird Meta ihre Transportleistung als Vorleistung für ihre
Online-Geschäftsmodelle weiterhin in Rechnung stellen.
Da bin ich jetzt mal gespannt, wie sie das, das glaube ich nicht,
dass die Rechnungen noch bezahlt werden müssen.
Und jetzt, also Meta missbraucht erneut seine überragende Verhandlungsmacht,
um berechtigte Anliegen der deutschen Telekommunikationsindustrie und der Verbraucherinnen
und Verbraucher zu diskreditieren und eine faire Bezahlung zu vermeiden.
Es geht hier nicht etwa nur um eine Meinungsverschiedenheit zweier Unternehmen,
sondern die Frage, ob sich im Internet die Macht des Stärkeren durchsetzt oder
ob es einen fairen Ausgleich unter den Teilnehmern gibt.
Wir wünschen uns, dass diese Debatte nicht auf dem Rücken der Bürgerinnen und
Bürger ausgetragen wird.
Auch ein Unternehmen wie Meta steht nicht über dem Recht. Das müssen wir mehrmals betonen.
Aber was ist das? Die wollen das Internet billiger machen und wenn Meta das
zahlt, das wird ja nicht passieren. So läuft ja Kapitalismus nicht.
Dass wenn jetzt Meta das gut bezahlt, dann wird mein DSL-Anschluss billiger
oder was? Das ist doch Bullshit.
Es geht noch besser.
Es gibt mehr Gigabyte beim Mobilfunk.
Der Fall unterstreicht daher den dringenden Handlungsbedarf in Brüssel.
Es bedarf europaweiter Regelungen, um eine Beilegung von Streitigkeiten zu gewährleisten.
Den Vorschlag der EU-Kommission zur Einführung eines verbindlichen Streitbeilegungsmechanismus
begrüßen wir ausdrücklich und so weiter und so fort.
So kann zum einen verhindert werden, dass Netzbetreiber künftig vor Gericht
ziehen müssen, um für ihre Leistungen bezahlt zu werden.
Zum anderen wird marktmächtigen Unternehmen wie Meta ein Riegel vorgeschoben,
einseitig und kurzfristig Verkehrslenkungsentscheidungen zu treffen,
die die Funktionalität des Internets insgesamt gefährden.
Also ich muss sagen, nachdem ich jetzt diese beiden Blogposts gesehen habe,
überzeugt mich ehrlich gesagt die Position von Meta, weil selbst der Blogpost
von Telekom beschreibt, dass Meta offensichtlich etwas völlig Akzeptables getan hat.
Aber ist das etwas als Datenmaut? Das ist das...
Wir nennen das Leitungsschutzrecht.
Das ist doch das Ding. Was die Telekom da meint, ist doch dieses ist doch diese Idee, die...
Telekom sagt, wir möchten am Content mitverdienen.
Letztendlich ja. Die Telekom sagt, wenn es euch nicht gäbe,
dann hätten wir diese ganzen Gammler hier weiterhin schön mit 56k versorgen
können und wir hätten niemals dieses 2G, 3G, 4G, 5G bauen müssen.
Und mit der Glasfaser hätten wir uns aussparen können. Und deswegen wollen wir von euch Geld.
Genau.
Also das wird noch sehr unterhaltsam werden, glaube ich, wie die beiden das
aushandeln, weil da wird sich jetzt natürlich zeigen, wer am längeren Hebel
liegt und ich habe da so eine Vermutung, wer das ist.
Aber so ein bisschen werde ich das Bild aus meinem Kopf gerade nicht los,
dass die beiden, also dass Mark Zuckerberg und Tim Höttges gemeinsam nackt in
der Badewanne sitzen und so ich so, wer, aber ich kann länger, weißt du?
Und ich glaube, Meta kann ein bisschen länger.
Ich meine, was passiert denn jetzt? Stell dir mal vor, der Fall würde eintreten,
dass jetzt auf einmal Meta zwar erreichbar ist, aber halt sehr langsam über Telekom oder Netflix.
Das ist ja genau der Punkt.
Ja, was würden die Leute machen? Würden die Profiler wechseln?
Die kündigen bei Facebook ihre Konten.
Mein Instagram-Account gebe ich einfach auf.
Weil Facebook nicht Fair-Share macht.
Ja, scheiß auf die die 30 Millionen Subscriber.
Ja, aber es geht ja um mehr. Es geht ja um Netflix, um alle möglichen Dienste, um Messenger.
Am Ende sehe ich es eher als Angriff auf Netzneutralität, oder?
Natürlich, deswegen hat natürlich auch hier Epicenter Works,
die NGO, in der Thomas Lohninger aktiv ist,
zeigt auf, die widersprüchliche Argumentation der Internetanbieter.
Erstens, obwohl die ISPs recht haben, dass die Menge an Datenverkehr konsistent
wächst, wird die Idee, dass daraus riesige Kosten entstehen,
nicht einmal von ihren eigenen Statistiken unterstützt.
Vodafone, ein großer ISP, der selbst für Netzgebühren wirbt,
schreibt, bei ihnen sei der Datenverkehr schnell gewachsen, während die Kosten
pro Gigabyte noch schneller sinken.
Zweitens, der Vorwurf der ISP, dass Inhalteanbieter nicht zum Netz beitragen
würden, ist konsequent falsch.
Inhalteanbieter investieren nicht nur jährlich hunderte Millionen Euro in Inhalte,
welche die Nachfrage nach Internetzugang, also den Produkten der ISPs fördern,
sondern investieren jährlich auch Milliarden in interne Infrastruktur,
die ihre Daten praktisch direkt zur Haustür der ISPs liefert.
Hat und das ist jetzt genau auch das Ding, also Beta und dieser Transit-Anbieter
alle mussten irgendwie investieren, damit die Daten bei der Telekom ankommen.
Das erspart den ISPs jährlich Milliarden an Kosten.
Daneben investieren viele Inhalteanbieter auch in effizientere Enkodierungen,
hochauflösende Videos und so weiter.
Laut deutscher Telekom sei es üblich, Interconnect-Fees zu fordern,
doch auch in diesem Fall zeigen die Statistiken das Gegenteil.
2011 forderten nur 0,27% Prozent aller Direktverbindungen Interconnect-Fees
und 2021 nur noch 0,0004 Prozent.
Es ist also weit weg von üblich.
Und viertens, die Kundinnen der ISPs zahlen bereits für die Internetverbindungen
und ihren Datenverkehr.
Mit einer Datenmaut würden Inhalteanbieter für dieselbe Verbindung zur Kasse gebeten werden.
Das wäre so, als würde man in einem Restaurant für Essen bezahlen,
Aber der Koch müsste den Kellner noch extra bezahlen, um das Essen auch wirklich
zu den Gästen zu bringen.
Ohne Taxi hier, aber Restaurant.
Da gibt es verschiedene Varianten und Bilder, die man da bemühen kann auf jeden Fall.
Tja, ich habe natürlich, also ich bin gleichzeitig, also es ist schwer,
also es ist sehr schwer, wenn zwei solche Konzerne, die jetzt beide nicht,
so richtig die coolsten sind. Also Telekom als Marke, wie auch immer.
Ich bin ja auch Kunde da, aber ich habe jetzt nicht den Eindruck,
dass die Telekom die ganze Zeit nur mir gegenüber karitativ auftritt.
Die tun alles für dich.
Die kämpfen beim Meta für deine Rechte.
Zum Beispiel von mir aus, ich würde sagen, schaltet scheiß ruhig ab.
Also ich, und macht das mir günstiger von mir aus, ich brauch keinen Meta.
Gar keins? Ich überleg auch gerade, benutze ich irgendeinen Dienst von denen?
Also ab und zu lade ich was bei ins.
Zillermeter.
Alles das gleiche. Ne, also tatsächlich würde es mich auch wenig treffen.
Ab und zu krieg ich so Instagram Links mit, hier guck mal und so.
Das wäre schon schade, wenn der Instagram weg ist.
Wieso?
Weiß ich nicht.
Nicht mehr was kaufen sollst.
Nicht mehr was kaufen sollst. Also Targeted Werbung weg.
Also ich meine, das muss ja nicht weg, aber diese Diskussion muss halt irgendwie weg.
Also es kann nicht sein, dass sich da alle gegenseitig ausbeuten.
Wird es ja nur teurer für uns.
Die kleinen Leute im Internet müssen dann wieder.
Man sieht hier, glaube ich, ich glaube, wir können zu dem Schluss kommen,
man sieht hier, wie schlecht die Idee ist, wenn man halt essentielle Infrastruktur
in privater Hand gibt, statt dafür zu sorgen, dass hier wirklich ein Wettkampf
auf einem Markt stattfindet.
Aber ich habe, ich meine, es tut mir auch, also ich fände es jetzt nicht so
schlecht, wenn Meta von seinen Milliardengewinnen etwas abgeben würde,
um bei uns die kaputte Infrastruktur zu reparieren.
Ja, aber das kann man ja einfach über Steuern machen. Das muss ja nicht die Telekom bekommen. Ja.
Sondern ordentlich Steuern zahlen ist nochmal eine andere Frage.
Ich denke, also genau. Die Telekom spitzt hier ja so auf, dass sie der Anwalt des Bürgers ist.
Ehrlich gesagt, weißt du was, ich glaube, warum dieser Telekom-Blogpost da gestrichen wurde.
Also diese Passage auf den Telekom-Blogpost, wahrscheinlich hat da jemand angerufen
und gefragt, seid ihr wahnsinnig, warum leitet ihr sowas überhaupt an die Kunden
weiter, wenn die damit Wahlen manipulieren und Steuern nicht mehr ziehen.
Ich glaube einfach, da hat die Rechtsabteilung Alarm geschlagen,
hat angerufen und hat gesagt, ey, hört ihr es, Alter, wenn du richtig viel Ärger
bekommen willst, dann lässt du das noch weitere fünf Minuten online.
Aber das tragen wir nicht mit.
Ja, Meta ändert die Einspeisung ins Telekom-Netz.
Die Telekom hat vorgebaut, um Qualitätseinbußen zu verhindern.
Ja, ich denke, das ist die Meldung. Das ist hier eine Bildunterschrift,
aber ich glaube, damit wäre die Meldung dann auch erklärt gewesen.
Aber es auf einer, also wenn man jetzt mal mit hier wie Thierry Breton,
der ist ja übrigens weg, ne?
Der ist weg, ja.
Warum?
Der hat sich mit der Neue Regierung.
Oder?
Die hat ihn rausgehört. Die hat Frankreich empfohlen, jemand anders zu nehmen.
So ein bisschen mit der Argumentation, dass sie ja gerne mehr Frauen im Programm hätte.
Da ist er wahrscheinlich gut bei dir mitgelandet. Mit dem Argument.
Die lagen sicherlich jetzt nicht so auf einer Linie, hatte ich so den Eindruck.
Der war eh so ein industrienaher Typ.
Der kam ja auch aus der France Telekom.
Deswegen hat er ja auch so dieses Leitungsschutzrecht so veröffentlicht.
Und jetzt kommt eine Frau von Facebook.
Cheryl, wie ist seine Nummer?
Keine Ahnung. Oder irgendein Schauspieler.
Der Kommissar der Konzerne dankt ab.
Ja. So, dann kommt ein letztes, ein kleines Urteil gegen Lipgen.
Library Genesis wurde allerdings in Abwesenheit verurteilt von einem Gericht
in New York. Das finde ich auch sehr interessant.
Was ist das? Lipgen?
Das ist eine Schmink-App. Lipgen.
Folgst du nicht Lipgen auf Insta? Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Was das ist.
Das hatte der Arne hier zuletzt in der Sendung auch erwähnt.
Libgen Library Genesis ist einer der größten E-Book-Marktplätze im Internet
ohne Bezahlfunktionen.
Okay.
Primär vor allem auch im wissenschaftlichen Bereich enorm gut.
Also ein guter Shop.
Ja, vor allem ohne die Zahlfunktion.
Vielleicht soll ich mal den Podcast hören.
Ja, musst du mal zuhören.
Das ist ein bisschen viel verlangt.
Also Library Genesis, die werden, gibt es schon relativ lange,
ist ein sehr, wenn du LibGen googlest, findest du die auch, ist immer unter
irgendeinem anderen Domain und die...
Weiß ich natürlich alles. Ich muss das nur fragen, damit das ja auch nicht erklärt wird.
Ja, ja, weißt du doch. So, und jetzt hat ein New Yorker Gericht auf Antrag mehrerer
Verlage, die Betreiber rinnen von Library Genesis, zu Schadensersatz in Höhe
von 30 Millionen Dollar verurteilt und zwar relativ einfach.
Und zwar haben sie festgestellt.
Bis zu 150.000 Dollar Schadensersatz pro Buch Und die klagenden Verlage hatten
200 ihrer Titel auf dem Portal gefunden.
Macht 30 Millionen US-Dollar. Und das müssen die Betreiber jetzt bezahlen.
Allerdings konnten die in ihrer Klage die Betreiber nicht benennen.
Und das Gericht hat auch keine Anhaltspunkte.
Also Unbekannte wurden jetzt verurteilt. Mit dem Urteil verbunden ist aber auch
ein weitgehendes Verbot mit Libgen zu kooperieren.
Zum Beispiel untersagt das Gericht, dem illegalen Portal Server und Domainnamen
zur Verfügung zu stellen.
Verboten sind ebenfalls Proxydienste und Browser-Erweiterungen,
die zur Umgehung von Providersperren dienen.
Ebenso ist es untersagt, Zahlungen für Lipgen abzuwickeln oder Werbung auf dem
Portal zu schalten, das jeden Monat Millionen Abrufe verzeichnet.
Also sie haben jetzt im Prinzip sämtliche Geschäftsbeziehungen mit denen verboten in den USA.
Immerhin, da sagen wir mal, gilt in weiten Teilen dieses Planeten als ein signifikanter Markt.
Ja klar, aber solange die Webseite von woanders hier seine Domänen erhält und
direkt erreichbar ist über IP-Adressen, dann greift das jetzt erstmal nicht unmittelbar.
Aber das dürfte eine der weitreichendsten Sperren sein, die es überhaupt in
dem Bereich jemals gab. Also sicherlich in den USA, aber wahrscheinlich auch weltweit. Tja.
Spannend.
Also nochmal schnell Lipgen runterladen, bevor sie uns das auch noch wegnehmen.
Und damit sind wir beim Ende der Sendung angelangt, mit einer kleinen Terminankündigung,
aber du spielst das Stringel ja schon gar nicht mehr ein.
Das ist ja gut. Warum nicht?
Weil sich mal alle Beklagen, dass es zu laut ist oder zu leise oder falsch oder so.
Ja, aber mach doch mal eine richtige Lautstärke.
Was ist denn die richtige Lautstärke?
Kommt jetzt Werbung oder was?
Jetzt kommt der Werbeblock.
Nee, wir haben ja diesen Termin-Jingle hier.
Es ist zu laut.
Zu leise.
So, jetzt musst du anfangen zu erzählen. Ich mach's ein bisschen leiser.
So ein bisschen DJ-mäßig.
Dann wird's ja weh wieder von Studio Link weggefressen. Also Ende Dezember lädt
der Chaos Computer Club unter dem Motto Illegal Instructions zum 38.
Chaos Communication Congress nach Basel.
Nein.
Dresden.
Neuseeland.
Hamburg, Hamburg, Hamburg.
Die Kongresse des... Ich lese jetzt hier nicht deinen ganzen Artikel vor.
Kannst du da nicht einfach freie Rede machen? 27.
Bis 30. Dezember in Hamburg. Jetzt fragen sich einige, was soll dieses Motto?
Was ist das überhaupt, dieser Kongress?
Es geht um technischen Widerstand gegen Überwachung, Vermessung,
Datenschnorcheln und Infiltration.
Und der Chaos Computer Club hat eh schon gesagt, wenn das hier...
Was gegen Infiltration?
Oder für.
Für oder dagegen. Das ist am Ende auch egal, oder?
Hauptsache in aller Konsequenz.
Hauptsache illegal.
Ja, es ist wieder Kongress. Okay, aber mit Alle.
Demokratischen Lebensformen sind eingeladen.
Was die AfD nicht Komm.
Ich mach jetzt hier mal die Musik raus Jetzt reden wir einfach mal darüber Okay,
also Kongress findet statt So und Ja, das 38. Mal.
Genau, und das Motto ist.
Illegal Instructions Das finde ich ein tolles Motto Finde ich gut Weil es mein,
Wie nennt man das? Mein internen Test für gute Motti sozusagen erfüllt.
Es muss irgendwie so mindestens zwei Denkweisen haben, wie man darüber nachdenken kann.
Richtig.
Und es hat natürlich diesen unmittelbaren technischen Bezug,
den wir jetzt so gerne lieben.
Wenn man jetzt also dem Prozessor da irgendwelche Zahlen im Speicher zurollt
und sagt, hier führe mal aus und da kann er nichts mit anfangen,
dann führt es halt normalerweise.
Und geht nach Bad Gateway.
Ja, definitiv. Da muss er dann
zu Bad Gateway gehen und das führt in der Regel zu größeren Problemen.
Aber auf der anderen Seite haben wir ja heute auch einige illegale Instruktionen
schon hier durchgekaut, die also
aus unserer Perspektive illegal sind oder zumindest auch illegitim sind.
Und da kann man sich natürlich dann auch breit drüber unterhalten.
Und wir können uns vor allem überlegen, wie wir mittels Illegal Instructions
Sand ins Getriebe der digital-kapitalistischen Überwachungsmaschinerie streuen können.
Sand ist aber ich Ich hatte einmal Sand in meinem Überwachungskomputer hier unter.
Der Tastatur Das war bestimmt nicht schön Mit dem Butterfly Keyboard früher
Das ist eine harte Ja auch schon Staub,
Brötchen Krümel Ja Staub Staub im System Gibt es auf jeden Fall schon reichlich
Den könnte man mal rauspusten Ja.
Mal schauen, was der Kongress dazu beitragen kann. So, das heißt,
wie viele Monaten gibt es denn Tickets?
Bissen wir alle noch nicht.
Das werden wir hier dann auch ankündigen, wann es die Tickets gibt.
Ich würde sagen, in dieser Sekunde.
Also CFP gibt es aber schon, oder?
Wir müssen mal ein paar Tage. Ich habe hier irgendwie ein Mail liegen, das sind noch CFP.
Aber erst mal ankündigen. Da gibt es keine Tickets.
Aber naja, bucht schon mal. Nee, ist ja in Ordnung.
Ja, also Kongress. Also völlig überraschend.
Völlig überraschend. Ja, das stimmt.
Genau.
Gibt es nicht offline lieber wieder? Nee, online. Hier gibt es online.
Nicht nach dem Kongress.
Kongress auch. Kann man online gucken. Streamen und nachher die Aufzeichnung gucken.
Ja, das ist auf jeden Fall eine Menge zu holen. Gut, ich denke,
wir sind jetzt am Ende der Sendung.
Ich muss mich dann auch auf die nächste Veranstaltung mal konzentrieren,
weil meine geht ja auch schon in drei Wochen los.
Subscribe.
Jetzt müsst ihr den Jingle wieder hochfahren, oder?
Der ist endlos, der läuft sogar jetzt noch weiter.
Im Prinzip läuft er noch, man hört ihn bloß nicht. Das ist das Geheimnis.
Ja, dann musst du dich doch nicht wundern, dass es zu leise ist,
wenn du das einfach einfach wegdrehen.
Naja, ich finde ja, also der, guck mal, wenn die Musik kommt,
dann macht man das Ganze, dann hat man die Announcement-Stimme drauf.
Dann hat man so einen Ankündigungs-Ton. Da ist man im Modus. Verstehst du?
Dann hat man eine spezielle Ansprache und klingt nicht normal.
Okay, kannst du das mal zeigen für die Subscribe, wie du das machst mit Musik
und so in diesem Ankündigungs-Modus?
Ja.
Ja, richtig so.
Subscribe, die Podcast-Community-Konferenz in Deutschland, die Maßstäbe setzt
und die Community zusammenbringt.
Dort trifft Technik auf Erfahrung und der Erfahrungsaustausch ist das,
was dich richtig zum Schwingen bringt. Subscribe, sei mit dabei.
18. bis 20. Oktober 2024 in Berlin.
Subscribe.de Subscribe.de.
War noch frei?
Klar. Hatten wir alles gesichert.
Subscribe.de.
Geht, oder?
Geht, ja.
Gucken, ob es hilft. Also 18.
Bis 20. Oktober in Berlin.
Kommt mal alle.
Okay. Subscribe.
Wird ein interessantes Programm. Anyway. Jetzt machen wir aber Schluss.
Markus, vielen Dank fürs Kommen, Mitdenken und Mitfühlen.
Danke für die Einladung.
Ja, immer. Gerne.
Komm in fünf Jahren wieder.
Ja, du kannst immer anklopfen und dich einladen, wenn du ein interessantes Thema
für uns hast. Das hast du eigentlich immer.
Meine Erfahrung. Linus, sagen wir Tschüss?
Ja. Aber mit Mozilla, was machen wir jetzt?
Gibt es hier nicht die...
Da können wir jetzt nichts machen. Wir suchen einen neuen Bookmark-Manager,
auch wenn alle doof sind und keiner unsere Anforderungen erfüllen wird.
Am Ende ist es immer das Gleiche, man muss es selber machen.
Das ist das Einzige, was hilft.
Probieren wir auch, aber es ist schwierig.
Und wir suchen schon, wenn die Chat-Control ist, einen neuen Messenger auch.
Da kommt ein Messenger.
Die Diskussion in den Kommentaren.
Bitte.
Wir können einen Netzpolitik-Org schreiben.
Wir wollen einen Messenger, der automatisch verändert.
Okay,
wir machen Schluss. Tschüss Leute, bis bald.
Tschüss.